foreign
good morning everybody welcome to this
meeting of baber District Council
cabinet I'm councilor John Ward leader
of baby District Council
may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements first please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other
speakers if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
please note that messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'll now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
declare
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members we have councilor
mccrore councilor McLaren councilor
Ayers councilor Mabry councilor Dawson
Council Lindsay and councilor bear in
attendance I believe that's everybody
and we also have our chief executive and
our monitoring officers are joining us
today
thanks Claire right I'm gonna move to
the agenda so item one apologies for
absence
we have no apologies for absence chair
thank you
item two to receive Declarations of
pecunery and non-pecuniary undressed by
members
are there any to declare
um
councilor Osborne yeah thank you Mr
chairman just on the budget side of it
the general fund I am a trustee on the
citizens advice
thank you
right moving over to item three which is
BCA 2026 confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting of the paper cabinet held on
7th of January 2021.
moving to the minutes in your agenda
pack I'll go through Page by page so
that's um page seven is the first one on
your agenda pack
um page eight if there are any comments
page nine
page 10
page 11.
page 12
and page 13.
if there are no comments then may I have
a proposal for the minutes please
I'll propose those John yeah thank you
councilor Davis and Council Osborne you
second
yes Mr chairman thank you
okay
um thank you um so the governance
officer will now conduct the electronic
vote
thank you Claire thank you chair members
if you could go to your mod.gov app and
select the plus sign in the top right
hand side
under this item the vote should now show
in progress
[Music]
thank you chair that's um seven votes
for that's unanimous
yes I do apologize councilor Davis uh
yeah can I take your vote verbally
please four
thank you that's eight votes wheelchair
thank you excellent right um item
forward to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
number received yeah okay thank you item
five questions by councilors and we do
have some questions by councilors um the
first one is from councilor Fraser I
understand councilor Fraser is not here
um in which case I will read it out on
his behalf
and it's uh baber's High Street
businesses are still currently closed
for trading due to govern government
covid-19 rules and guidelines and Hadley
there has still been no consultation
with any business organization or the
Town Council which resulted in
considerable protests against these
parking proposals
although proposed changes will not now
be implemented any sooner than 1st of
October 2021 this will still be too
early for businesses to have made a full
recovery and assess the impact on them
of This Global pandemic
um impact
on them of This Global Panic pandemic
has had on him sorry that um I was
reading at verbatim there
um more time is required more time which
could be used to form respected steering
groups to discuss this issue but also
future matters that impact on high
streets and how best to regenerate what
is the heart of our communities so that
we can all benefit and take ownership of
High Street management and policy going
forward
would you therefore agree with me that
baby should wait until at least first of
April 2022 to implement any changes thus
giving appropriate time to engage with
the respective Town councils Chambers of
Commerce and other relevant
organizations
I'll now invite to councilor malvisi to
respond
casanovici thank you very much Mr
chairman
um I know that the covid-19 pandemic has
hit businesses hard
um and to date BDC has paid out over 27
million pounds of Grants to support the
businesses in our district
there are 10 grants still open and I'd
encourage those who need it to apply
go to the baber district council website
clickbusiness and then business rates
and you will see the area for covid-19
grant funding schemes
I attended the council
um meeting where the petition to keep
free parking in Hadley was debated I
also attended the overview and scrutiny
committee where the original parking
paper was also debated
this dear to us was clear from both
meetings more free time
and a later implementation date
the overview and scrutiny committee
specifically recommended one hour free
parking
and uh not before September or October
and we've elected to not before October
implementation date
we've listened
we agreed with this recommendation as
you will see in the report before you
today but please also recognize that if
we are not covered free we will revisit
the implementation date
the comprehensive strategic parking
review that we've committed to in this
paper answers your point on the need to
deal with future matters that impact the
High Street
we will consult on The Wider issue of
parking both on street and off Street in
our district with residents businesses
and other key stakeholders to make sure
we're prepared for the next five to ten
years and this work is due to begin
later this year thank you very much
thank you councilman ovc
um Claire I've just had a message from
councilor Fraser saying that he needs an
invitation to this meeting for some
reason he hasn't got one is it possible
to send it send it to him
I'm online now oh you are yes thank you
chair councilor Fraser has just um
emailed me okay thank you
uh councilor Fraser um uh now you have
joined us do you have a supplementary
question
um I'm very sorry actually I've just
this uh moment joined so I miss that my
supplementary question it's off the off
um it's not written down I do apologize
for that is
um what measures are baber taking to
communicate with our High Street
retailers independent retailers and
business partners partners at the moment
considering that we're currently in this
tier five lockdown so that we have this
Lane line of communication with them
prior to implementing any changes to our
parking measures please thank you
councilman VC do you have a response at
this stage or or do you wish to come
back with a written response later I've
got a sort of partial response um thank
you councilor Fraser
um
[Music]
the change in pricing
of the car Parks requires a consultation
so we will be going out for consultation
in that period
um and obviously whatever we pick up
during that con that consultation period
um we will then
retain the knowledge and apply it to the
actual strategic parking review
um that we
as noted in the paper that we hope to
start later on this year
thank you counselor thank you thank you
uh councilor malvisi uh Mr chairman and
my apologies for my uh late joining
that's okay counselor Fraser thank you
for your questions
um now I'm going to move on to the next
question um councilor Lindsay
um I'd like uh would you like to ask
your first question please
[Music]
yes thank you chair
um
so my first so I've got two so just the
first one Brighton and Hove Council
um just uh a few days ago they're going
through the same process as us they they
set up a sustainability and retrofit
Reserve
of four million pounds in their housing
revenue account
starting in
um the
2021-2022 financial year
um this is to retrofit the council
housing stock in order to meet their
goal of zero carbon by 2030.
um in view of the urgency of addressing
the climate challenge why doesn't baber
set aside a similar Reserve beginning
2021-22
a financial year to help meet our Target
thanks
thank you councilor Lindsay councilor
Osborne
um would you like to respond
yeah thank you Mr chairman thank you
councilor Lindsay for your question uh
both the district council is committed
to the aspirations of decarbonizing our
existing Council housing stock
along with our broader commitments as
part of our motion on a climate
emergency and more recently our carbon
reduction management plan as well as our
homes and housing strategy
currently work is taking place by
officers to develop a revised housing
revenue account business plan which will
set out our Ambitions and our financial
commitments in the medium and long term
we expect to bring this work forward
during the summer and we will ensure the
development of our plans involve members
through meaningful involvement and
consultation
we know that a recent National Housing
survey has put the cost of
decarbonization at 20 20 742 per
property whilst the figures provided by
the social housing sector range from
three thousand to fifty thousand per
home for us the cost could be up to 70
million whilst we know that the cost of
retrofitting the social housing sector
is estimated nationally at 104 billion
it is for these reasons that we do not
see any benefit to creating a specific
reserve for our HRA housing stock in
relation to retrofit and sustainability
especially when the required investment
is so significant in addition to the
whole landlord service and all the
initiatives we wish to undertake to
improve our services for tenants
our work on the development of our
business plan requires a
transformational approach which utilizes
our ring fenced income and ensures that
we can provide our existing tenants with
high quality safe accommodation that
provides tenants with Benefits such as
affordable energy bills whilst
supporting our wider environmental aims
this inevitably will involve looking at
invest to save initiatives in order to
free up Monies to enable us to meet the
huge challenge in making our existing
housing stock carbon neutral
as demonstrated we need to maximize our
HRA receipts to support the improvements
to our existing stock while supporting
our Ambitions to build much needed new
affordable homes for our residents
this is why we are committing 21.5
million during the next four years to
our Capital program for housing
maintenance and renewal and a further
16.2 million to new build and
Acquisitions during the same period
hence creating a reserve is not the
solution and a broader review of how our
HRA assets and limited resources meet
all our aspirations will be carried out
and put forward in the forthcoming HRA
business plan
I would like to add that this Council
has a history of environmental
improvements to our Council housing
which benefits our tenants and The Wider
environment
historically this may have been
re-roofing homes installing double
glazing or installing central heating I
would however Point directly to the
large solar PV program that took place
in
2014-15 and has resulted in greatly
reduced bills for our tenants
warm homes grant that has historically
provided hundreds of air source heating
systems Loft and cavity wall insulation
programs
currently the successful bid for the
green homes Grant which will provide
environmental and sustainability
improvements to 38 Council homes in Baba
or to the awaiting decision on our bid
for the second round of the green homes
grant funding
an external wall insulation program will
begin very shortly which will benefit
and improve a number of homes in great
cornard as well as work being undertaken
in springlands in Sudbury together with
more properties in baber thank you Mr
chairman
right there thank you councilor Osborne
councilor Lindsay do you have a
supplementary question
um yes yes please um I just wonder how
so so I think what you're saying is that
um you're not going to commit any
set some certainly not this year
um and we don't know what you're going
to commit
to retrofitting homes to make them
um you know Carbon zero
um at least until you produce this
business plan
um
I just wonder how that squares with the
commitments in the carbon reduction plan
which said that the officers were going
to draw up report to assess exactly what
the needs were for
um retrofitting the council homes and
that was supposed to be by the third
quarter I understood the third quarter
of the current Financial year
so in other words it's already passed
that passed in December
yeah though we will be committing some
money in the HRA plan but not
necessarily ring fencing a large amount
and we need to we need to think outside
the box and to be Innovative in our
approach rather than simply setting
monies aside as mentioned in my response
we will be reviewing how we can meet our
combined aspirations and how they can be
delivered but we need to strike a good
balance between delivering on our carbon
reduction plan and also providing homes
for those affordable homes for those in
for those in need I think as far as the
the lapse in the timetable I think it's
fair to say that the covid-19 a lot of
our resources have had to be directed in
other places but we will pick up with
that and be running with it but the HRA
business plan will be coming forward
two two cabinet within the very near
future and they I think then councilor
Lindsay you will um have more of your
questions answered within that new
business plan thank you Mr chairman
thank you councilor uh councilor Lindsay
would you like to ask your second
question please
uh yes thank you
um the um
Suffolk this is in relation to the um
car parking charges
um they Suffolk climate change
Partnership of which baber is part has
proposed that a reduction of 25 percent
uh in car use in Suffolk by 2030 is
required to get to Net Zero by 2030. uh
it is building consensus amongst the
business Community for this target uh to
get there will require baber to produce
a 10-year plan really to match that goal
for 2030 to invest in public transport
cycling walking and car sharing so
people have an alternative to car use
there's been virtually no investment in
active travel in the past decade by
paper
why are we implementing car park
charging without having drawn up a
costed timetable plan for investment in
active travel
thanks
thank you councilor malvesi uh would you
like to respond please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
councilor Lindsay for his question
the Suffolk climate change partnership
will flag up the need for a significant
reductions in car use in the Suffolk
climate action plan
which is currently in production
however the Suffolk climate change
partnership will not be leading on
measures to achieve the reductions
that will be for transport and planning
Specialists across the authorities to
deliver
which includes baber
through new sustainable travel officer
who has only recently been recruited and
will be producing a plan
the council agreed early last year to
recruit a sustainable travel officer and
I can confirm that Catherine Davis
started in this role on the 1st of
February
Catherine will be responsible for
delivering the SEC
a fully costed and prioritized
sustainable travel plan which picks up
on walking cycling public transport
which of course is a county
responsibility and other opportunities
that may exist the plan will take some
time to develop and it is right that it
is developed alongside any measures
around car parking
thank you
thank you councilman visi
Council Lindsay do you have a
supplementary question
um yes just thank you for that answer
um it's great news that we've got a
sustainability just a travel officer um
can I just confirm is that the same
the the motion we had a motion on
cycling that was unanimously passed by
the council quite recently that called
for a
um sort of resources for officer
resource for cycling is that um kind of
seen as part of that
or is there a I thought there might we
might be hiring a sort of cycling
officer but I'm guessing this is a
that's all part of
the sustainable has cycling you know I
guess the question is sorry I'm I'm
ad-libbing it I guess the question is it
does does cycling come into the um
sustainability
officers remit
the short answer is obviously yes
because within the parking
um paper that we presented today we're
trying to get it to be cost neutral so
that we can actually put in parking Bays
rather than see the bicycles tied up to
Saint Peter's railings and other such
um
things dotted around around the town
okay uh thank you you're welcome
okay uh thank you councilor Lindsay for
your questions and thank you councilman
avici for the responses moving on then
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or jointed audit
and standards committees
I'll now invite customer craw chair of
the ovian scrutiny committee to
introduce his reports
councilman crawl
thank you Sharon good morning members
and uh public uh
we've got three sets of recommendations
from overview and scrutiny uh from the
meeting held on the 18th of January
rather than go through them in detail
they're in front of you the six
recommendations uh in the first paper we
looked at BCA 2027
um make specific reference to two points
that have already been covered in in
discussion of the previous questions and
particularly like to draw attention to
the recommendation 1.2 I'm very glad to
see that the cabinet and officers picked
up on the recommendation that the
parking management principles and
interventions detailed in the appendix
should be implemented no sooner than in
our case the first of September and the
point was that that was quite deliberate
for the very Point mentioned by
councilor maldizi to allow flexibility
due to whatever outcomes May emerge in
the next few months and I think
hopefully addressing the concerns
expressed by councilor Fraser
regarding the other change that we've
made to the recommendations that were
presented to us the provision for one
hour of free parking we felt was a
sensible compromise towards a rational
uh decision in that um
the situation as it existed could no
longer be described as sustainable and
you'll be dealing with this matter later
in a later report so that for the moment
covers the Town Center car parking
the second set of recommendations if you
can call it a set would be you do also
hope you should have you have minutes
for that meeting in front of you
uh I do apologize but my screen is
slowing down whilst I scan onto the
second set of recommendations
that was a lengthy set of papers to go
through just to get there and frankly I
need now to find uh uh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no my apologies chair
I'm having some difficulty in uh getting
my screens to respond that's okay
counselor from memory I'm operating
entirely here from memory uh the second
set of recommendations concerns the
budget
um and that we recommended
recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 to the
cabinet with the exception of any
subsequent effects from our parking uh
recommendations which will be debated uh
today the third set of recommendations
concern the HRA
um
just scanning down the page and I've
gotten too far
we supported the recommendations 3.1 to
3.7
in the report to cabinet that you have
in front of you and in both cases you
have a full set of draft minutes as
those have yet to be adopted
um that's all I can really report to the
uh the um
cabinet
thank you councilman crawl uh we've all
um seen the the minutes
um and uh the recommendations
um and thank you very much for the the
work that you have done in scrutinizing
the the parking paper and also that the
draft budget so that we've had your
input into today's proceedings thank you
very much
Right Moving on then item seven the
forthcoming decisions list
does anyone have any comments on that
nope we've all had a chance to look at
the um forthcoming decisions list
um
and uh oh counselor Busby your hands up
yeah thank you chair just a couple of
quick things
um first of all could you
change my telephone number to my mobile
number rather than home number please
and then I've got a question on
um
uh one of the items
I didn't understand
and just go through find it
uh
I can't lay my hands on at the moment
I'll actually
um raise that outside the meeting I
think
okay thank you counselor
right if nobody else has any questions
on the forthcoming decisions list we'll
move on to the next item on the agenda
which is item eight paper
bca2030 these are special urgent
decisions taken by officers during the
covid-19 pandemic
under delegated powers in accordance
with part two of The Constitution
so I'd like to introduce this report
which is for noting only what you have
in your agenda pack and it's detailing
the special urgent decisions that have
been taken for decisions over 150 000
pounds and which are exempt for calling
and these have been taken in Concept in
consultation with the chair of the
council and and taken by officers using
their delegated powers during the
pandemic there are two decisions that
are detailed in appendix a of your
report
um
uh one concerning the additional
restrictions Grant scheme and the other
um the local restriction support Grant
scheme
um does anyone have any questions on
that but as I said it is for noting only
in which case then we'll move on to item
nine which is paper BCA 2032 the car
parking study report and I'll now ask
the cabinet member for environment to
provide an introduction councilor
malvisi over to you please
thank you very much Mr chairman
um
as most people are aware the town
parking report was originally prepared
for cabinet on this for the 7th of
January
it was not considered at that meeting
but was instead deferred
to a review and scrutiny committee so
that the petition submitted could then
be debated at full Council
therefore the report has been Rewritten
to take into account the discussions of
both of these meetings together with the
various other submissions received from
members of the public
I've considered all that I have heard
and have changed the recommendations in
the report to reflect this
I was asked to extend the free period to
one hour
which we've done
I was further asked to push the
implementation date to up to not before
October 2021
and again I've done this
I would like to clarify at this point
that the report is purely about baber
District car parks there are many areas
of on-street parking in our towns and
Villages that are free to park on
and they fall under the remit of the
County Council because they're highways
I wrote to both Sudbury and Hadley town
councils as well as both Sudbury and
Hadley Chambers of Commerce to tell them
about the new recommendations
the town council's reply to me jointly
asking for the decision before you today
to be postponed until after the
comprehensive parking strategy review
the comprehensive strategic parking
review to which we are committed in this
paper we'll deal with future matters
that impact our high streets and
therefore our car parks
the decision today is about what is
needed now to address the current issues
we need to ensure that there are spaces
now for people to park when they are
visiting the towns
we also need to make sure commuters and
workers Park in the best places to allow
this we need to invest now in our car
parks to a standard people ex expect to
see and we need to play our part in
increasing air quality in these areas
I was asked why I'm proposing a motion
on car parking many presume car parking
is a political Hot Potato that is too
dangerous to touch
but we're not elected to run scared of
controversial issues we're elected to
try and do our very best for the entire
District
the best way I can explain my reasoning
is by recounting a request from our
Council chairman councilor Grandin
Catherine asked me to meet her to assess
the small car park at the Hadley Railway
walk
we visited this sorry excuse for a car
park
the grass verges are practically
non-existent
and if you do drive up there please put
your Wellies on before you get out of
the car because half of it is a swimming
pool
the signage is also poor it needs
replacing the whole car park needs
repairing
and that's going to cost money
and where's that money coming from
what also struck me with a number of
commercial vehicles parked there
mid-afternoon I doubt these people were
out walking their dogs anecdotally I was
informed that people actually parked
there all day thus depriving others from
enjoying the facilities of the Walk
this also added to my own experience of
locating a car park when visiting prior
to moving to the area
as a newbie I found North Street Car
Park illogical in both its entry and
exit
and not very well signed posted for
either
are there really exit and entrance signs
an arrow maybe I'm blind
I didn't see them the car park outside
the Kingfisher Center is confusing
if you are not from the area
shared space is one thing but Clarity is
also required especially if you're
looking to increase visit numbers to the
area
relating my experiences to Cassandra
Clements our assistant director
it was felt that the cost being borne by
baber for discretionary Services meant
that money which could and should be
spent on other things were suffering
as we all know the importance of car
parking is not just in the quality of
the facilities for each motorist but in
the effective car parking management
which should be designed to balance
traffic management and environmental
impacts with support for local residents
visitors workers and the economy
the introducing the climate change
action plan followed by the biodiversity
plan also highlighted the need for
bicycle parking and because of the scant
provision and currently in Sudbury
they're tied to the wrought iron
railings around Saint Peter's Church
not very attractive
also both the climate change action plan
and the biodiversity plan addressed the
need for electric vehicle charging
points
for both cars and electric bikes and I
suppose electric scooters
baber is to successfully deliver all
these objectives for our residents then
change is needed and it's needed now
but the question remains how are such
improvements to be funded how do we make
baber car parks cost neutral able to
stand alone without incurring costs to
be borne by baber taxpayers
I'm not going to give you a little bit
of background to myself I randomly NBA
in retaining and wholesaling in the
world at The Institute for retail
studies at Sterling University
long before that on graduating from
strathclyde University I was one of the
first graduate intakes into marks and
Spencer and I can tell you that people
do not drive to a town simply to park
for free they drive to a town that
offers them what they're looking for and
if what they want is not available they
then drive to wherever it is available
so for Sudbury and Hadley that's usually
Berry and Colchester
where parking is anything but free
and the other alternative is that they
go online
the retail mix in Hadley is very
different to Sudbury and it's obvious
from their mix that Hadley gets used on
a regular basis the Shoppers possibly
shop every day or every second day
because there are two bit butchers an
award-winning Delicatessen a new green
grocer stroke Deli
which indicates either a fairly constant
footfall
or a reasonably High one because these
are all what a turn in the retail sector
are termed as short shelf life products
the shops are Independents delivering an
instant personalized service making
shopping in Hadley more of an experience
Allied to the wonderful coffee shops
that are there all independent and
they're less likely to be driven online
Sudbury on the other hand while having a
few independent shops and especially the
largest winch and blatch the town has
basically been dominated by multiple
chains such as boots Iceland peacocks
and eminco and not that long ago had a
Woolworth under Marks and Spencers in
North Street but all of these offer
online trading the banks are online
so what can you not get online
hairdressing
Cafe
you need to visit them
however baber has put together a vision
for Sudbury and Hadley these are very
exciting plans to develop the center and
in fact the plans fit in with a town
center review about to be published by
The Institute for retail studies and
also Bill's grimsies
who happen to be the former
CEO of Iceland
their acclaimed review into the future
of the High Street
The Institute for retail studies has
identified the need for our town centers
to be greener
offering facilities for cyclists both
pedal and Electric
the claim that free parking will bring
people into shop is a fallacy people
will travel if the offering is what they
want
Sudbury has not moved with the times for
example Marks and Spencers an anchor
store in most towns even today
with covid they pulled out
what something like 10 years ago because
footfall was already falling
so this further confirms that free
parking does not bring Shoppers into
town
Sudbury and Hadley have a lot to offer
the tourist sector
in fact both are pursuing tourism
Sudbury has got Gainsborough house the
history of silk then bent an end
as I've mentioned earlier our car parks
are not visible to visitors
I consider myself still to be a visitor
and for the first four years living here
it was difficult to get roundtang
the big retailers only let you park for
two hours
Tesco sainsbury waitrose
once you start parking there and you're
there for longer than two hours and
you're visibly not in the store
you'll be clumped and they're quite
ruthless about it
I believe that a revised policy is
needed a policy that moves our car
parking provision into the 21st century
that enables car parking to become cost
neutral that produces a revenue stream
which will enable baber to move to more
sustainable travel alternatives to
provide electric vehicle points in all
its car parks to have electronic signs
that indicate availability thus remove
the need to be driving round and round
trying to find a space
and emitting pollutants
spaces for residents through the use of
Resident permits signage that encourages
visitors to use the appropriate car park
and then walk around the town to see
what's on offer
now's the time for us to make the
changes in preparation of the car
parking strategic review which will take
anything from 18 months to two years to
complete which combat combination will
ensure that our towns and Villages are
not only sustainable but will Thrive
into the future for all our residents
visitors our economy and our environment
it's time to make it's time to move away
from the approach to parking that may
have worked in the 70s or 80s and may be
even the 90s of the 20th century but no
longer does today for the 21st century
and I recommend recommendations 3.1 3.5
in the report thank you Mr chairman
thank you councilman avici for a very
thorough introduction
may I have a seconder for this report
please
councilor Busby would you like to second
well actually chair I'd like to make an
amendment to one of the recommendations
if I may
um can we pick that up in the debate
section please
well only the
if you're going to set us for a second
now then
it just prolongs it I think we can agree
the recommendation
right um what what is the amendment
you'd like to meet then please counselor
well one of the recommendations that
came out of ons which we haven't picked
up
and I'd like to tack on to the end of
3.5
so that says that a longer term parking
strategy be developed for the whole
district and that the review work to
develop such a strategy commences in
quarter two of 2021-22 I'd like to add
on this strategy should ensure that a
proportion of income generated from
chargeable parking will be allocated to
the delivery of the sustainable travel
agenda
right okay
um we would have to first vote on when
we do come to vote on that amended
recommendation
and then either that gets accepted or we
go back to the original recommendation
if if not but
um at the moment then uh we'll we'll run
with this as an amended recommendation
um and you'd like to second that sorry
Claire it's Claire if I may we will need
to have the original recommendation
seconded before we can then propose an
amendment okay all right thank you thank
you okay may I have the original
recommendation seconded please
chairman if I may I think the monitoring
officer wanted to intervene okay oh uh
sorry Emily I didn't see your hand
not a problem chair um and Claire did uh
tackle one part of the advice that I was
going to give so the um original motion
as proposed by councilor malvisi needs
to be seconded
um but then if there is an amendment you
can deal with that now so if counselor
Busby then proposes his Amendment and
there is a seconder for that amendment
that should be debated before you move
back to the original motion and so
that's that's the order that should be
followed chair okay thank you very much
may I have a second for the original
recommendation please
um well I will second that
um so councilor Busby you've proposed
your Amendment may I have a second there
for councilor Busby's amendment to
recommendation 3.5 please
counselor yeah I'm happy to second that
Amendment raised by councilor Busby
thank you okay thank you we will
therefore debate the paper with that
amended recommendation at this stage
Right Moving on then
um first of all questions sorry chair
could I just come in and you actually
need to debate the amendment first so to
see whether it's accepted by the whole
County
that Amendment yes that's right so it's
just questions and debate on the
amendment then you'll take a vote on the
amendment unless of course you and
councilor malvisi wish to accept that
Amendment without debate
councilman VC
thank you chairman and thank you um
Emily
um
I don't see any reason why we shouldn't
adopt that Amendment
because if I've if I've if I've
understood councilor Busby he's asking
that
um some funds not all funds
some of the funds
um
garnered from the price the charging
to go to a sustainable travel policy and
that sustainable travel policy which
should come out of the car parking
review
thank you uh councilor Holt do you have
a comment on this
yeah I must admit I I thought we were
allocating some funds within the paper
anyway so I'm not sure how that fits in
with what we were what was mentioned in
the paper the other thing is chair
um I would like to discuss Apostle
amendment to
3.3 I'm happy to do it later on or
whether you want to get them all out of
the way now
um is entirely up to you get them all
out of the way now please okay on 3.3
um
I need some clarification or some
altering of the words the residential
parking permits uh be implemented in
Mill Lane Car Park Sudbury for overnight
stays I have an issue with the phrasing
overnight
um from my point of view I've always
pushed for them to be 24 7. I'd like
some clarification on the definition of
overnight
um that car park is used or
predominantly be used by residents who
will be there for 24 hours a day not
just workers who come back in the
evening so I'd like some clarification
as to what overnight actually means and
if it does mean what I think it means I
would like that reworded so that it's a
residential car part for residence to
park 24 24 hours a day seven days a week
are you happy to accept that change yes
I am because I actually think that's
what was intended yes I I agree with
that
okay
um
um chairman can I just point out that
the reason for the decision which is
under item three
um at the last element
well the last Clause says and to fund
investment into sustainable travel
projects so that
could indicate that councilor Busby's um
motion
is not necessary
because it's it's already covered yeah
Council Busby do you want to comment on
that
sorry I don't see where that is in the
recommendations sorry
underneath recommendations to cabinet
3.1 to 3.5 then it's reason for decision
to make changes in respect of parking
management blah blah blah blah blah and
the last Clause is and to fund
investment into sustainable travel
projects
I agree that's fine but I'd still like
to see it in the recommendations I think
it makes it stronger
okay okay right well we've got two
um proposed changes to the
recommendations
um uh councilor Osborne do you have a
comment
yeah thank you Mr chairman no I'm just
going to say in respect of um second in
councilor Busby's uh amendment to that
recommendation I'm still happy for that
to continue even though it is
highlighted elsewhere in the report I
think it does give it that much more
clout I'm also
um willing to a second uh councilor
Holt's amendment to 3.3 I think it was
for the change to just removing oh just
overnight I'm happy to second that one
as well thank you Mr chairman
uh Council Davis
yeah thank you um and I I agree um that
it should be 24 7. however I'd still
like to know councilor Holt asked the
question what defines overnight stay in
is there a set time or set hours uh just
not for Mill Street obviously but just
in general
um I think I'll I'll ask
um Cassandra if she can confirm that but
I believe overnight would be between 6
p.m and 8 A.M
um unless anyone would like to
contradict that
thank you would you like me to answer
that question yeah yes please thank you
and I think it's a it's a valuable
question to bring up um essentially the
parking order at the moment um stipulate
certain times that it can be parked in
um and that is
um predominantly across the piece eight
until five so the wording here talks
about introducing overnight so just to
clarify that would end up being 24 7
um but I will make sure that we make
that very clear
thank you Cassandra
okay
um uh thank you members of the cabinet I
don't think we um perhaps need to uh
go uh dwell on this any further we've
we've got two recommended changes to um
or proposed changes to the
recommendations and um I think I'd like
to go ahead with a vote on that please
Claire is that possible for us to
approve those recommendation changes I
am going to need to um
add a new vote into modgov for this
um could we have we will need to agree
on a wording though
so if I could ask councilor Busby
chairman could I also ask that this
reworded recommendation because you're
accepting the amendment so it's becoming
part of the The Proposal
um could that be circulated quickly
could we have the reworded
um
proposals perhaps Zapped through by
email or something just so that we're
absolutely clear on the on the wording
councilor Busby are you able to
um send that through please
um
no
um uh actually I've found a copy here in
an earlier email of yours yeah I did
circulate it too yeah okay I'll um I'll
just um send that to
Claire and the cabinet
and just a question if we're going to
vote on these amendments
and that it's accepted does that take
away any room for debate
before the vote
no it does not
um uh it all it means is that the the
wording of the recommendations in 3.3
and 3.5 will be different and we'll be
uh proceeding with the rest of this uh
particular item on the agenda
um with that revised wording
determine if I can just step in again
and help with the process
and the cabinet will need to vote on the
amended wording to 3.5
um first so that's one Amendment that's
been proposed and seconded and then
they'll need to be a second vote on the
amendment to 3.3 which was to remove the
word overnight
so there'll be two amendments to vote on
if they're accepted they become the
substantive motion and then the cabinet
can return to debating the entire
recommendations
thank you Emily
could 3.3 say that residential parking
permits be implemented in Middle Lane
Car Parks Sudbury to include overnight
stays
I think we've just um
take out or
um they get the word overnight stays and
just
um
at 24 hour residential parking permits
be implemented in the middle and car
park Sudbury that's all we need to say
yeah
I have circulated councilor Busby's
revised uh recommendation 3.5
confirm chair I just need to um input
that into the mod guard to set the vote
up so I'll be a couple of minutes whilst
I do that that's okay thank you
actually cheer while we're waiting can I
just ask a quick question on the table
two the
the charges uh will they apply to
Sundays as well
no
okay thank you
okay members so we now have uh the First
Amendment
ready which reads to vote on the
amendment to recommendation 3.5 for the
longer term parking strategy be
developed for the whole district and
that the review work to develop such a
strategy commences in quarter two of
2021-22 this strategy should ensure that
a proportion of income generated from
chargeable parking will be allocated to
delivery of the sustainable parking
agenda travel agenda apologies so I will
now start that vote for you and then we
will move on to the second amendment
whilst that's in progress can I just
check councilor Davis are you now logged
in
foreign
thank you that is um eight votes four
chairs so that's unanimous I'll Now set
the Second Amendment
second one will
actually Claire there's a slight
spelling mistake on that Amendment oh
okay I'll go in and change that later
thank you oh yes I put allu gated
the amendment to recommendation 3.3
I can't see that in modgov at the moment
I'm Now setting it up oh sorry
and this is to remove the word overnight
uh it's
um so that 24 hour
um residence permit parking will be
um
available I don't know if I I've got to
go back to the report now
that um 24-hour residential parking
permits will be implemented in Middle
Lane Car Park Sudbury subject to the
strategy order process and requirements
for consultation yeah and that removes
overnight yeah
okay
all right so if I just read this back to
you before I confirm it uh 24-hour
resident parking permits will be
available to Residents in Mill Lane
Sudbury
yeah okay subject to uh
that's the order
okay I will now confirm that and we will
be ready to vote on that one
this is
that should now show yes I can see that
thank you
just waiting for one more vote
thank you uh chair that's eight votes
for so that again is unanimous thank you
Claire right great so we've got amended
recommendations now
um we will be going through and uh
debating the paper with those amended
recommendations so we're moving back on
on to the order of proceedings firstly
questions from cabinet members and um
these are questions
um on the uh the content of the paper
prior to being able to go into debate
later I'm going to do this in reverse
order this uh this this time this
meeting um so we'll start at uh with uh
Castle Parker
uh yes can you hear me yeah yes um yeah
I have got a question um chair and it
may well spill into debate um a little
bit later on as well but much of the
comment that I've received um from
residents particularly in Sudbury is
there concerns around
um what the
um uh what the consequence of of Charles
parking might do for on-street parking
and residential areas
um now I I don't have any issues and I
don't think that it's material to the
paper and the principle of charging but
it is nonetheless a concern
um for residents and and from my
experience because I do Drive In on a
daily basis outside of covid drive into
park at Sudbury car Parks I use the the
Kingfisher car park and my experience is
the Edgeworth Road key Lane Ingram's
Well Road
um are all chocker Monday to Friday so
there is a concern from residents that
um that uh charge parking will amplify
that situation although In fairness you
can only there's only a finite number of
parking spaces you can't you can't park
in any more spaces than there are but
nonetheless is it something that we've
um that we've taken into consideration
um in in our deliberations please Joe
thank you
uh thank you
um I think uh perhaps um maybe Castle or
even Richard uh given that um he's done
quite a bit of the um Research into this
um either one of you be able to answer
that
of course chair yes thank you and and
I'll bring Richard in uh if we need to
uh after this so thank you very much for
the question councilor Parker and I
think that's a really relevant question
so displacement from the car Parks
absolutely is one of the elements that
we look at when
um any kind of behavior change
um principles are implemented within car
Parks so um looking at the the Sudbury
area one of the original issues that
came up with this car these car Parks
were that
um the the spaces were taken very
quickly and people were staying long
staying them part of the um using the uh
tariffs as a tool to move people to
different spaces means that there'd be
more availability in these car Parks so
it was felt by us that we didn't feel
that there would be an issue with
displacement because actually what we're
trying to do is open up the spaces in
those car parks for the people that want
to use them there is actually quite a
significant amount of free on-street
parking in Sudbury as well well that has
a combination of uses from our
observation so there are a lot of people
that park there for for a fair while
um but there are also quite a lot of
areas that have restrictions you know
one hour two hours and which means that
there is a lot of churn so it absolutely
is an area that we we looked at before
suggesting terrorists as a tool
um but we felt that the displacement
issue would not be a large one what we
do have however is
um two other things that can assist us
one we have our civil Enforcement
Officers whose role it is to go out and
make sure that people are parking
properly on street and in our car parks
and secondly we have our area parking
plan which is our support mechanism to
Residents and businesses if they feel
that there are issues on the street that
we can help them apply to Suffolk County
Council for some changes in those areas
thank you Cass
councilor Osborne do you have any
questions at this stage
uh well I was going to ask exactly thank
you Mr chairman I was going to ask
exactly excuse me the same question that
councilor Parker has just asked because
obviously in our Market towns there is a
problem with um on-street parking
um some of the buildings just weren't
built to accommodate three or four cars
at a time
um but
um Cassandra has answered that query so
thank you very much but I will be
joining in the debate thank you Mr
chairman okay councilor Holt
any questions at this stage
what caught me out there
um
yeah parking permits uh for residents
workers
um we have something in place at the
moment in Sudbury I I dislike
confirmation of whether that is is also
district-wide and is available in Hadley
as well and what we've done today uh to
promote this um for when uh charges if
the paper is passed come in
um to enable workers employees and
businesses themselves to promote and
possibly find ways to to help staff fund
them
um is that something we've done quite a
bit of work on and how far along are we
with them and I just say I know we've
got them but I don't think they're
widely known that they're there so I
think it's something we need to to
promote and do work on and I just want
to make sure that we're on top of it
thank you councilor um yeah I agree the
promotion is has probably not been as
good as it should be I do know they are
available in the maglin road car park in
Hadley as well but um uh councilor
malvesi or Casper you'd like to comment
on the um uh publicity and promotion of
these cash just just before I I ask Cass
to um provide us with the details
um both councilor Holton yourself Mr
chairman are correct in that they've not
been promoted as effectively as they
should have been
um and that's what we want to put right
so over to Cass yeah thanks
thank you very much and thank you for
the question councilor Holt so
absolutely we do have residential
permits at the moment that are across
our baby District car parks and I would
agree with councilman vasey I think
they're there for people that know that
they exist uh the residential permits
are a thing and look for them or we
happen to have had a conversation about
um what we need to do is
um make much more effort in promoting
those to people I'm sure this debate
today will do that to a point
um but we absolutely need to play our
part as well what I would like to do is
look at permits as a whole so not just
residential permits but look at business
permits as well because there's people
with very different needs for permits
you know there's shift workers there's
um residential there's uh business users
so I think we need to look at it as a
whole rather than just specifically
residential permits
thank you thanks counselor Davis
uh no I don't have any questions to add
I'll wait till the debate thank you
thank you councilor Busby
uh no I haven't either thanks
councilor arthi
no questions from me from me thank you
right before the cabinet moves into
debate then I'm going to open it up for
questions from any other members of baby
District Council present
um and normally this is um purely for
asking questions of
um surrounding the content for
clarification purposes but given the um
uh the huge interest uh I am going to
allow a certain amount of discretion and
what constitutes a question
um but that is only a certain amount of
discretion so um uh please try to focus
on questions but uh I do appreciate that
you might want to say a few other things
as well so firstly the first hand that I
have up is councilor Grandin
thank you Claire
um I have I have first of all
of all of them
um that I haven't noticed the answer to
in the report
what hours
are the chargeable hours does it finish
at five o'clock or what time because
we've also got to think about the
nighttime economy so that's my first
simple question could that be answered
please
councilor marvisi forecast
yeah
very happy to answer that question uh
thank you councilor Grandin absolutely I
can confirm that the the uh charges are
Monday to Saturday and they are 8 A.M
until 5 p.m Sundays
um there are no
um
restrictions and bank holidays there are
no restrictions
thank you
because honestly some days everything is
closed in Hadley anyway so that's not
really that much help
um I'm very disappointed that um
Saturday afternoon is no longer
currently you don't even need tickets in
Hadley car Parks from noon Saturday till
Monday
um so that's disappointing to lose that
um free Carefree time
um from noon onwards
um on Saturdays
um so uh I'm very disappointed that
we've only got an hour
um free parking and that it's and that
the charged for time Still Remains at a
pound
um so
does and and also the other thing I'm
concerned about is everything being on
the green agenda and because
baber is not paying for for example the
green uh the
cycle parking and so on Town Council is
organizing and paying for that anyway in
Hadley so you know that shouldn't be on
um considered as something that babe is
doing
the car park the route the railway walk
car park that councilman keeps referring
to was something that I drew the
attention to
um a few years ago
um and was has been on on our list
to do anyway
um
my other concern is I don't feel that
the debate at the
full Council has been listened to by
cabinet
um nothing in this paper seems to refer
to
having listened to the debate at full
Council it only seems to have listened
to the very favorable motion that was
voted for in overviewing scrutiny
thank you thank you councilor um for for
your comments there
um I I will ask
um
cast to pick up on the the cycling
provision because I know that baber has
plans for
um cycle storage alongside
um electric car charging and charging
for other EV uh vehicles uh electric
vehicles
I take uh uh I take a point about um
uh the uh the debate at Council but um
the the motion there was a very specific
one
um and we have uh taken on board
um the the the context of the debate in
that motion but um Cass would you be
able to pick up on
um uh cycle storage and another
provision like that please
certainly chair thank you very much and
also my uh colleague Fiona dumo is in
cabinet which might who may have some
more detailed information but I know
that firstly with the uh changes to the
Leisure Center there's additional cycle
um storage provision being put in as
part of that Capital spend and also that
in the area of Market Hill as part of
the active travel One Fund
um new cycle parking has been put in but
perhaps Joe if you'd allow me if I could
invite Fiona who I believe is on the
line who could give some more detail
yeah thank you Fiona would you be able
to good thank you
yes uh so just to
um reiterate the point earlier that we
have obviously appointed a new
sustainable travel officer Catherine
Davis
um Catherine will be tasked with looking
not only at cycle routes but also cycle
provision
um and
um the other point I just wanted to make
is that uh Michael and I had a good
discussion with the Town Council and
with the newly reformed Hadley chamber
uh the other day
um and um were talking to them about how
we could start to look at locations for
cycle storage and we've had a similar
conversation in Sudbury obviously in
Sudbury we um we've obviously installed
new cycle storage through the active
travel one
thank you very much thanks uh councilor
Grandin do you have any other questions
before we move on to um the next person
in the list
no only to say though that
well I think it's
it's great that let
dord I actually never see anyone using
it in the the two places that we have in
Maiden wake up or it's very maybe I've
seen people use that a couple of times
No I um I agree I mean I um I've never
seen cars in there when I ever I go to
Hadley and and past maidenway but um the
fact of the matter is they they are
there
um it is part of our uh strategy to to
help move to carbon neutral and and um
along with all sorts of other
organizations and providers to ensure
that there are sufficient EV charging
points throughout the district so um we
just have to wait for the greater uptake
of um electric vehicles electric cars
and no doubt they will start to be used
um increasingly as as the years go by
yeah thank you thanks uh councilor beer
you're next
thank you uh you can hear me and see me
thank you Mr chairman cabinet members
um I I have tried to alter what I'm
going to say by some of the things that
you've already said but bear with me uh
I'd got a statement which I've put into
questions there's about six there
members my emotion of September 2019
asking for Park and reviews the long
time coming I'm told possibly starting
later I'm in this year in the meantime
no consultation or Communications with
myself or other members Nino Hadley and
Sudbury councilors have been involved
only with the North Essex parks in
Partnership presumably these are a
consultant that we've employed and I'd
like to know how much has that cost the
taxpayer of baby District Council they
say in their report and I go from all
the papers you've sent out that the car
parking charges do not discourage
visitors also the introduction of charge
is not solely for generating income
unbelievable that
the independent parking study
commissioned by baber has spoken to uh
has not spoken to the people affected by
this
baber you have not listened to the
people who are complaining and who have
written letters
with their views and their comments to
the local press radio and send emails
and letters to members
and have submitted two separate
excellent petitions from Hadley and
Sudbury containment of around
2660 plus signatures
how does the cabinet justify ignoring
this
balanced traffic management the needs to
support local residents visitors and
workers and grow the commercial
viability of our towns
what do we get instead page four
paragraph 5.3
development and regeneration support the
delivery of Town Projects this is the
removal loss of parking spaces on the
market Hill so the simple answer is
charge more for Parkin and give less
parking spaces in return it's
acknowledged in all this that it will
have an impact on the loss of parking
spaces so with less spaces to park
motorists would have to look to the side
streets I did hear councilor Parker
mention this and the residential and the
residential areas to park their cars
also this discouraged
past and trade to stop park and go
this will damage our economy the High
Street it is hitting people very hard
Traders and shopkeepers with all the
proposed council tax increases
and the return eventually of business
rates increase parking charges there
will be less money to go around and less
spaces depart what is your answer to all
that we already had many empty shops no
major Outlets less footfall because we
have seen an explosion to online
shopping and major Banks encourage you
to go online and this will continue if
we pursue our blind Obsession to destroy
the center of our towns by charge and
more on our free parking is not long
enough time for some of our elderly
residents and young families depart and
go shopping
much is made of the environmental and
green issues we all support carbon
carbon reductions and yes we need to
look at other modes of Transport like
e-bikes and electric vehicles that would
be encouraged but remember members the
motorers will certainly be playing their
part by 2030 if they want a new car then
they will have to buy electric so they
will certainly be putting their hands in
their pockets to help pay for the
empowerment and all we do is reward them
by increasing car parking charges I'm
nearly at the end
well I have different charges for eight
paper this will only confuse people it
should be the same tariff throughout the
district
and why exclude latinum car parts it is
a tourist Village and the one place
where you would expect to pay
and you choose not to do so
also you can't seem to agree on a staff
date the only date I would agree on is a
no new date at all finally
I would not support any increases in car
parking charges and the resultant loss
of parking spaces in Sudbury
if you're now moving to a vote and it
goes through it will be a death blow
doubt by baber to our towns submarine
Hadley brought about by eight members of
a Rainbow Coalition cabinet thank you
thank you councilor beer
um I've made a note of um one or two
questions in in that
um uh and I'll see if
uh Cass can can pick up on those I'll
try and summarize them
um the one that I would I would probably
like to address myself is is
um listening to the views of the
petitions and and also the
correspondence we've received and we
have received a lot of Correspondence
um
and that there is in in much of it
um an acceptance
um sometimes with more or less
enthusiasm that we are trying to
compromise and the compromise that we
are proposing today
um is something that that many people
can live with because they do understand
um the imperatives that are driving uh
that the need to uh to change our
parking tariffs
um but um for many people the one hour
free is is
um uh quite uh quite a useful uh change
from from 30 minutes I'll pick up on uh
when it comes to debate uh I have more
to say on that matter but in terms of
questions
um the specific one of the specific ones
you wanted to know how much um we've
paid for uh the North Essex parking
partnership to uh to advise us on this
um along with that if Cass could give us
some indication perhaps
um it needs to be set into the context
of of what that money has actually
provided us with because it has been
very helpful in drawing up today's paper
um the the other thing about um loss of
space on on Market Hill well that is
obviously something that um and County
proposing as part of uh The Joint vision
for the center of the town that um and
uh the redesign of of Road layouts Etc
bus stops and whatever
um maybe Cass can can come back with
some some comment about how we're
addressing that
um uh loss of space in in the short term
because obviously
um castlebar you and I know that in the
longer term
um our parking strategy May well as as
it has to address future capacity
requirements so we we will look at
providing additional capacity elsewhere
um
uh I think uh
I'm just trying to see what what um
other questions were buried in in that
um those are the two key ones I thought
that came out for me um
is there anything else specifically that
you would like answered as a question
um the the latinum car park over at the
start dates the start date yeah well
we'll come on to start date when when we
go into debate in fact fair enough don't
mind
um uh and I think um perhaps Cass can
you uh make any comment about uh
lavender and and the situation there uh
I know we'll probably pick up on that uh
ourselves in in debate but um uh if
there's anything that can be said at
this stage so um uh Cass sorry to sort
of uh drop these on you but are you able
to provide any uh responses to councilor
beer on on those points I can thank you
chair and thank you Chancellor beer for
the question so on the um work done by
North Essex parking partnership that has
totaled 11 000 pounds and that has
covered
um numerous visits out to site
um not looking at not only the car Parks
themselves as an asset and what's
needing to be done to them but also
observations of parking they have done
all of the analysis of the data that the
council holds on how um the car parks
are used so the number of tickets issued
when and and any long stay charges as
well but though specifically we did ask
them to look at the shorts day and so
they have done the analysis of all of
that data and they have helped us
um look at what the recommendations
should be and the reasoning around that
so um they have been as you rightly said
our Consultants on on this part North
Essex parking partnership were chosen
because of their proximity to baber and
also because of their wider part that
they play in um parking across um the
British Parking Association as well so I
felt that they had very adequate um
qualifications to help us do this piece
of work
and then um chair I believe you asked me
to talk about loss of space so um I
think you actually probably covered it
for me but um in terms of using Terraces
at all to move people that that is the
um tool that we're using to make sure
that people are using the right spaces
for the uh stay that they're doing so it
was seen from the observations and from
the data that came in that there is
enough parking in the car Parks if long
stays were in the outer car parks and
and creating availability and the ones
closer to our high streets so there is
enough availability it's just people
wanting to to pop in
um to pop to the bank or do something
you know short we're not willing to park
so far away and we're either idling in
our car Parks or going around the
gyratory system to come back and try
again
um so in terms of loss of space now I
think we believe that there will be
capacity if we just move people to the
the right spaces in terms of future
capacity absolutely the comprehensive
parking review we'll be looking at all
of those wider issues
um and if I could just add a chair that
in terms of the um the the now the
consultation element of this is part of
any application for a new traffic
regulation order and so consultation
will happen uh if this decision goes
ahead today but in that comprehensive
parking strategy a significant amount of
consultation will happen to help form
the views of all the stakeholders
um both for both on street and Austria
in our districts
so just to be clear Mr chairman uh the
officer is saying that you will be
talking to those people motorists
affected by this because today you
haven't done so and that obviously by
um killing off the past and Trade Stop
park and go you won't be encouraging
that at all
and well there will be park and go
because
um
one hour free will provide that park and
go in the car Parks
um but um if you're referring to the
market Hill that that is a different
matter and um it's referred to in your
report that's why I brought it up but
anyway I take your point yeah thank you
um
okay then uh councilor Mabry you're next
uh thank you Mr chairman um I actually
thought councilor Dawson was first but
uh carry on yours is uh your name's
higher in the list
thank you very much Mr chairman
um I do have quite a few questions
quick and list them all at once or if
people would like me to stop and have
those answered that's absolutely fine
how many questions are there uh one two
three four about six
would you be able to pick two or three
of the most relevant then the others
will pick up on later because six
questions is is quite a large number
that's absolutely fine uh my first is uh
what cost will there be for permit
parking for those residents I haven't
seen that registered anywhere what is
the cost of permit parking
um particularly for those in Mills Lane
and from what I can hear from um other
areas uh second to that is what will the
cost be for disabled parking
that hasn't been clarified
or the actual amount of disabled
facilities that will be included in any
new strategy
uh ma another point I have is that
um I never assume another's financial
situation
which unfortunately I feel has been made
by the cabinet and offices because you
have failed to recognize that many
villagers do not have a local shop and
there's a huge amount of rural poverty
in those Villages so could you explain
what measures you have brought to bear
for that please
um
is that three or can I oh that's four
that's four go on you're done for us
we'll have the other two go
um
pineh for car parks
ever built to be all flashy or or busy
or
electrical is that
um I would like to know how much
electrical signage is going to cost and
the ongoing maintenance of it please
um I would also like to
say that I'm really disappointed that
although an amendment has been put
forward on 3.5 for the funding of
alternative travel there's no actual
percentage of the funding that would be
used so it could be deemed by the
council that yes there will be some
money put forward to to that but it
could just be the odd thousand there
should be a percentage I feel on that as
well
um and
um
my very last comment is about the
redesign of the market Hill the only
other place that I know where a market
Hill
with seating which had was slightly
bisected because you've still got
through traffic going through the town
the only other place that I know of it
was that Bromley
Unfortunately they had a few deaths from
which I have already raised the issue of
people have this false sense of
um
lack of security that it's okay to just
cross the road and unfortunately that
happened in Bromley there were a few
deaths and they had to change the system
completely and take out the uh parking
on the market Center thank you thank you
councilor um your last comment about
Market Hill is outside of the scope of
this it's um nothing to do with with
what we're doing no but it's relevant
um so
um your your
um comment about the percentage funding
for active travel that is not really a
question I've got four questions here
that the cost of permits which I can
answer straight away 25 pound a month 70
pound a quarter 250 pound annually are
the current costs as listed on our
website disabled costs I'll I'll try and
get an answer for that
um
um and uh disabled parking facilities
well again that's really more an issue
with um the the County Council but I'll
I'll um see if we can get a comment
about the disabled facilities in our car
parks and the electric signage costs is
is the fourth one
um
so Cass can you pick up on any uh
information we have about electric
signage costs what we're doing about
disabled parking in our car parks and
whether
um
and the issues around that and also the
um cost for disabled parking
I can thank you very much chair so
um so this is disabled parking as in uh
within just our car Parks I can't um
talk about on street I'm afraid but um
all disabled parking comes with a
concession currently in baber our
parking is free in terms of um how much
uh blue badge parking there is and
whether that's an adequate amount that's
something that I'd very much like to
look at as part of the comprehensive
parking review
um you have answered the cost of palm
permit parking um signage I'm very sorry
I'm on a single screen and I'm trying to
scroll down
um to our appendix a which details the
costs in this so I'm sorry I can't bring
the figure directly up to you
um I haven't got a maintenance figure
for you currently councilor Mayberry but
within appendix a we have detailed where
new signs are needed
um
all of the car parks to be fair signage
is needed it's exceptionally outdated
um the the conversation around electric
signage is is one that allows a user
when
um approaching a car park to see if
there are available spaces so it's not
um flashy in terms of uh making making
the car park attractive it's very much
one of information giving so um it's
there to say how many spaces are left in
the car park so somebody doesn't have to
drive around
um unnecessarily to that car park
um so I apologize chair that I can't
bring that number
um to you directly I can say that the
cost of within appendix say but I'm very
happy to do a detailed answer
um after cabinet for councilor Mabry
thank you very much
um Mr chairman I'm just going to come
back to um to Ms Clements because
um I know what the disabled parking fees
are currently which is nil
but what will they be in this future
strategy please will can you confirm
that they will still be nil
absolutely uh councilor Mayberry there
is no
um nothing in this paper that says that
we're going to start charging for blue
badge spaces it's short-term space thank
you
councilor Dawson
uh oh yes thank you share
um I I would just like to ask all
members
um when they're making their vote to
consider has the relevant information
being put forward to the cabinet
and that you're all properly informed
or done coming to the decision that we
baby have sought expert views or those
of others
and my feeling was certainly overview in
scrutiny my concern was we were not
presented with the right information we
had snapshot studies informal
observations at a low input point in
time which was February
we were not presented with historical
figures for comparison any full data and
other categories of information obtained
from algorithms or other pertinent
information
nothing was indicated regarding traffic
displacement or effects on business for
consideration and I think the way the
correct way forward be to birth this
until it is known or after the parking
review
and I was she just also like to add
um I think all this business about the
residence parking
um we've had quite a lot of discussion
about that as an alternative but we have
been already told by Suffolk councils
the northern starter because they
haven't got the money to actually put it
in place in Hadley
so you know we're bringing all this in
and um I think it's very disappointing
that we weren't given the full
information that we should really
required and it would assist you in
making an informed and relevant you know
making your your decision and I hope
that you will consider this and perhaps
defer it until after all this is known
the matter of residence
um uh parking um we just um talked about
that a bit earlier obviously on Street
residence
um permit uh schemes uh the
responsibility of the County Council but
we do have residents permits already
available in Magdalen Road in in Hadley
um and there is some issues over
promotion of that scheme so uh the off
Street residence permits are catered For
here what I will uh do um from what what
you have said there is ask Cass
um to comment about the the research and
the data that has been conducted on on
our behalf by the Essex parking
partnership that has informed this paper
today
um before I um pass over
um I I will clarify once again councilor
Dawson this paper is about the the uh
the measures and interventions that need
to be done now the parking review that
we're going to start
um this year is about the next five
years plus and what needs to be done
um in the longer term so
um we uh we can't put the cart before
the horses which is what um you're
suggesting but I will um now pass over
to to cast if you can comment on on the
uh research and the data please
I can indeed you thank you very much so
um there were physical
um observations taken out within the car
Parks um to look at the amount of cars
that were coming in and how long they
were staying and that was done on
weekday and weekend a Saturday
um
in terms of those observations that took
place they were married up with the um
ticket machines data that we have as
well and so in terms of a snapshot I I'm
afraid it may be just be terminology but
a snapshot in terms of two weeks I
believe that to be
um an adequate portrayal of what was
done instead of you know a six-month
survey This was
um over a two-week period in terms of
the low impact time I do agree it was
done in February and that is a low
impact time but for us that says it only
exacerbates the issues that we saw
during that low impact time when there
are far more users of the car park
um the informality the word informal uh
that is due to people standing there I
see that as informal data the ticket
data that came out
um for me it would I would class as
formal so I'm afraid these may just be
uses of words and I hope that's
clarified it I'm very happy to bring in
Richard Walker to talk about how that
all of that data was analyzed if that
would help um sure
I think yes if Richard could that um I
think um he would certainly have some
some background there that um I think
members would would appreciate
thank you Richard over to you
thank you Chan yes we've we've conducted
a number of surveys both observational
and uh data analytics surveys on site so
uh a separate company was involved in
doing the the two weeks of surveys that
Cassandra mentioned there and then I've
been on numerous occasions also no
Hadley and Sudbury and latinum very well
and visited them for uh for other
reasons myself so on on a lot of
occasions I've stood and taken photos so
I photographic evidence of what I've
seen
um to to confirm what was in the data
and to make sure that was telling us um
that the things that we've put into the
report
in terms of what you've called
algorithms
um I at Northwestern Department which
have a huge wealth of data about car
park usage and statistics and the way
people use car parts more generally and
I've used that knowledge to help inform
uh changing from the survey data and the
observations uh into the the likely
impacts that you have in the car parks
that you've got we know about different
types of town and different
characteristics of different towns so
I've used that Knowledge from the car
parts that we have right across North
Essex and six different districts and
the details there to inform us about the
types of parking that you might expect
and then given a range so it's an
estimate but uh best estimate
um based on the things that we've got
there from dwell time and probably your
least worst February observations which
then would impact a much greater
particularly at Christmas and there's
some photographs or queuing cars and
different things at Christmas
um and and the the sorts of impacts that
would
on the types of parking that you should
discourage in some places and
encouraging others and in order to free
up the types of parking which is right
for Shoppers
um in in the very center of Sudbury for
instance and then also to provide
um the sort of information around should
you have bigger Bays have you got the
right number and types of things in in
place at the moment in terms of signage
other machines fit for purpose is the
parking order right we've had a a long
review of the whole parking order as
well so all of that
is part of the work we've been helping
you out with I hope that helps in some
ways
thank you very much actually that's
that's very helpful right
very briefly then very briefly no
there's two points that haven't quite
been answered
um if Rich if you can clarify for the
cabinet exactly what you did
um how you analyze the traffic
displacement
and secondly the effects on business
which were not presented to us and those
are the two really important points here
so can you outline I I don't believe you
did anything in Hadley so again it comes
to Sudbury what you did to indicate the
traffic displacement you know with your
figures your whatever and and how the
effects on business
foreign
and drawing on some knowledge that I've
got from the British Parking Association
and some including some Publications in
there to which you can refer about the
The Walking time from car parks and the
likely impact that might have uh so I've
been to have a look at the different
restrictions on the street from the
traffic web service that Suffolk County
supplies and overlaid that with a 10 to
15 minute walking time particularly in
Sudbury we've had a look around there to
see if there would be any impact now
earlier in the meeting today we've had
that evidence from one of your other
councilors and said those spaces already
top a block so I don't think there's
going to be any more displacement into
places that are already full but as
Cassandra has mentioned you've got the
area parking plan which is your link
strategically with the County Council
and the County Council is the one who's
required to look at on-street measures
for Suffolk so the on-street parking
restrictions in Suffolk will be covered
by Suffolk County Council and the link
from the district to the county of
course is through the area parking plan
and all of this discussions that you've
already been having around the Civil
parking enforcement and the plans for
that
um so if you take that to stay further
the plans for civil parking enforcement
had to make sure that all of your
restrictions were correct and suitable
for purpose and before any of that was
introduced so there's been rather a long
run up into uh looking at all these
things which is why the report's taking
quite some time since last February to
uh to come to fruition
thank you Richard okay
um right we we've had a lot of questions
from uh non-cabinet members and I have
um as I promised I would exercise quite
a bit of discretion but I would now like
to move on into the cabinet debate at
this point
so thank thank you uh members for your
questions and your comments
um uh I know they've been very heartfelt
and um uh the cabinet uh has uh heard a
lot of that before and we will be taking
it into consideration but now uh moving
into debate uh firstly councilor Parker
would you like to open the debate please
yeah thank you very much Cheryl I will
do indeed because
um throughout all of the questions there
from uh from Members it is clear that
the overwhelming
um comment uh from them but not just
them but also uh you know the social
comment uh and and uh press comment Etc
um the otherworming comments there are
about concerns for our business
um and I'm not entirely sure if I'm
being honest I'm not entirely sure that
Richard
um answered councilor Dawson's question
in full and actually it's one of the
questions an additional question that
I've got here so what I what I want to
know is because obviously we've got a
weight of evidence before us as a
Cabinet we have got a weight of evidence
before us that is
um you know informed uh this very paper
that we're discussing here
um it seems to me that the uh the
evidence for the effects that that might
have on business
is relatively scant it's it's it's sort
of anecdotal so I I want to ask Richard
Walker because I don't think he did
answer the question what evidence
um is there amongst all of his
information uh that's been collected
over many many years what evidence is
there for the impact of business
um by way of Charles parking thank you
thank you Council Parker Richard are you
able to provide any information or
insight into that please we can uh
thanks chairman and thanks councilor um
yes there's a link to a document in the
report there from the association of
town center managers and part of that
considers the effects on uh talented
parking as a second document in there
from the British marketing Association
as well the evidence that those
documents uh seem to be suggesting is
that the amount of parking that's
provided is dependent on the footfall
that's provided by the offer in the town
and not the other way around so it would
depend on the types of offer that the
shops are providing so in other words if
Traders aren't selling the sorts of
things people want to buy then people
don't go to town and I that has been
found to drive the amount of parking in
the title parking that is required so
parking follows footfall to parking
follows the destination offer rather
than the other way around and there's
some links and documents in the report
that uh that detail a bit about that
um each of those towns has their own
particular characters so separate things
are at play in each of the town and with
evidence suggest different things going
on in those but that's the fundamental
the the overarching principle really the
the town provides
for for the amount sorry the term
provides parking that is it that the
shops are there to support
thank you Richard
Castle Parker did you want to uh say
anything further on that
uh no I'm I'm hoping that that um I'm
hoping that that in itself will will
spark the major part of the debate to be
honest because as I reiterate
um the concern overwhelmingly is is for
the business
um so that that's that's what we need to
uh need to tease out of this to
ascertain
um whether there truly is a a detriment
uh here thank you thank you thanks
councilor Osborne thank you Mr chairman
um if I could keep my part of the debate
until a bit later on please I'll come
back at a later day thank you
okay
um I'll move on to councilor Hulk next
thank you um following on from from
Lee's comments I think he's right I
think a business is is a key
issue in this debate and businesses
are I think obviously going through very
severe time at the moment with covid the
impact of covid
um and the re-emergence from from this
is is going to be critical to both
Hadley and sudbury's town centers
um both have a fantastic offer
and a great deal of variety
and independent shots that locals use
um I do find it strange sometimes that
we get a lot of flack and a lot of
comment from people saying if you're
going to charge a pound I'm not going to
use them I just I I can't comprehend why
people would say that
if they use them now why would they not
use them if they're going to support the
local economy why would you not continue
to do that if you're asked to pay a
pound over an hour
um so
I see a lot of comments flying around
how this is going to harm and destroy
our high streets but
we all locally have to support our local
economy
and by doing so we have to go into our
towns and and buy and and
shop and support those businesses
so
I think it's not an easy question to
answer but a lot of this is to do I
believe with with timing and we've
touched on that already
for our high streets
to have time to recover we need to be
very cautious of the implementation of
this
and we've gotten the paper from October
um and bearing in mind when this paper
was first drawn up
before it went to over over in scrutiny
in a full cabinet we hadn't had the
third lockdown we didn't know about the
UK variant
um this has had a huge impact nationally
death tolls Beyond where we'd ever think
they'd have been and
this has impacted this paper and it
continues to impact our decision making
on this so the timing of this I think is
more critical and people should be more
conscious of than necessarily the pound
that we intend to charge if it's
supported today
um so I would certainly like some debate
on timing my preference at the moment is
is certainly to keep it open
and I honestly feel at the moment we'd
be looking into 2022 for the
implementation of this
but the decision has to be made today
because
the procurement of the equipment the
organization of of contracts etc etc
does take time
so I think the decision needs to be
taken today on the parking paper but
timing is a key and crucial factor and
as I say
it's got to come back to Cabinet foot I
believe whenever we introduce it as in
the implementation date
but um
I honestly can't see it until 2022 but
that's all I want to say at the moment
thank you
thank you councilor counselor Davis
yeah thank you um I think councilor Holt
has summed up a couple of the points
that I was looking to make there as well
um I'll be voting for this and the
reason is because
um I'll have a listen to what has been
said
um both by the public in in terms of
through the media uh on social media
um and I've also listened to the
Consultants I've looked at the paper our
officers have put together a very
comprehensive case councilman malvesi
has has expressed in her introduction a
very comprehensive uh reasons why we
need to do this why we should do this
um and and the timing I think is
important as well but I've also not just
listened to those people who signed
petitions and have made a noise in the
media but the silent majority who have
been in touch to say we're right to do
this
um and and it's not just members of the
public and it's those residents in the
various towns but also the the Town
Council this isn't happy
um yeah they discussed at their Town
Council and I was very interested to
hear that on the whole as has already
been pointed out they understood that we
need to do this we that we need to make
these changes everyone or people are
much varied their views on uh how long
the free parking should be the the cost
afterwards whether it should be 50p a
pound or whatever but we've I think
we've come to a very sensible term
compromise because we have listened
because we have taken on board all the
comments we took on board the petition
at the uh at the full Council we took on
board all the councilors views there
which again was um 1414 you know so it
shows that not everybody is against what
we're looking to do on the contrary
um in a slight the the chair gave the
cast and vote but there were a couple of
abstentions as well so overall I think
we're doing the right thing and and like
I say I'll be voting for the paper thank
you thank you councilor Busby
thank you Jay well I have to stay up
front and I absolutely hate paying for
car parking
um
however
if I go to a place where the
attractions are such that I want to
visit it for the attractions then I'm
happy to pay for car parking
it's very rare that you would go to a
place just because it's free and if you
are then how much you like to spend in
that place
I think we we need to look at the the
Two Towns independently I think they are
totally different
um I would have preferred this paper to
have come after we've done the reviews
of the town we certainly need to make
significant changes and improvements to
the offer of Sudbury it has great
potential we need to get that potential
out
um Hadley is different I think people
actually do go to Hadley because of the
free car parking particularly those in
The Villages between Hadley and Ipswich
I know a lot of people therefore that
choose to do that they go to Hadley
rather than Ipswich
however
we have got significant expense
on the car parks and it needs to be
funded I'd like us to look at
alternative ways of funding that through
Sil Etc
but
if we are going to have to introduce car
parking to fund these changes
then this is a reasonable way of doing
it
um it's in my view it's
the first step
in a long process of improving the
desirability of our town centers
it might be the wrong way around but
it's here and now and it will enable us
hopefully to fund some of those other
changes that are desperately needed
thank you councilor
councilor arthi
yeah thank you chairman
um yeah there are a few things I wanted
to say
um first of all though
um I I think I just said that I thought
counselor Holt spoke very very well
um and of course he's got a particular
interest in um in the effect on business
um I've been a counselor for 30 years
now and this subject has um has ruined
its head quite a few times
um I think councilor beer has also
referred to the fact that he's been a
counselor for a similar period and
um he has always opposed charges and so
have I longer happened
thanks for the interruption but I think
there was a little bit of time where you
didn't get elected so you had a break
didn't you
um anyway no longer added up
um so yeah during that period I've
always opposed charges for for car
parking but I think there are three
three main reasons why I think
differently now
um so I'll just run through those
um the first one
um is about our initiative
um over the past six or seven years with
regard to our public realm assets and
town and Parish councils have previously
had the opportunity
um to consider being more involved
including taking over the management of
car parks
and out of all of our town and Parish
councils I think it's only lavanum that
have taken up that opportunity and work
is still underway their ambition of
courses to to take a lease on the car
Parks but they're already responsible
for additional maintenance both of the
car parks and the toilets
um in in their two car parks in lavanum
um so I think that is
something that's firstly important but
also I think in a way a little bit
disappointing
um that the town councils in both
Sudbury and Hadley didn't
um take advantage of the opportunity to
be more involved
the second issue that I think is
important now
um is the green agenda and I'm pleased
that um the leader of baber's green
group is listening this morning and I've
spoken to him about this
um previously and I think I agree with
him that we cannot continue to encourage
car use by offering free parking
we we do want to encourage the retention
of
um certain what all businesses in the
town centers but there are certain
um businesses that offer
um things like um Opticians dentists
vets doctor surgeries other
um health related providers
um somebody previously mentioned
hairdressers and Barbers I think these
These are Town Center uses where
um people are likely to have an
appointment
um usually they last about half an hour
um and the one hour free period
um that we're now providing or
suggesting would would allow such
appointments
um to to be attended um with that with
no charge for parking
the third reason
um that I think things are different now
is to do with our budgets and
um and equity
so 25 years ago
um council tax for baber I think was
around about 25 pounds per year per
property
um now we were we rely much more on
council tax to support our budgets
and it's it's not simply it's it's not
fair for everybody in the district to
subsidize car users in and around
Sudbury and Hadley
um now I know that there are people in
surrounding Villages that rely on the
services offered in in local towns and
I'm one of those people
um you know I'm I'm about four miles
from Hadley um about six or seven miles
from Sudbury and I use both of those
towns
um but I I just don't think it's fair
that there are so many people
particularly in the east of the district
um who are subsidizing the the car
parking that they don't use indeed if
you're on the shotley peninsula and you
want to go down to pin Mill
um you actually have to pay to use that
car park at the moment
so those are the three reasons why I
think
um the debate today is different to the
debate that we've had
um at various times over the past 30
years
um I think we've we've had a lead from o
and S and I very much support the 103
um and I agree with ons that an
implementation date in July would have
been far too early given what's happened
with covid and everything that councilor
Holt explained
um and I I welcome the fact that you
said chairman that um the the
implementation date could be further
reviewed
um depending on how we how we come out
of covid
um so that's what I wanted to say on
that there was one other little note
um that I made whilst um other people
were talking and it's as a result of
councilor grandin's question regarding
the use of EV charger points there are
two things about that one is
um the point of planning infrastructure
is that you you do it up front so we get
criticized a lot for
um uh an issue that arises and we're too
late to address it and we should have
done something sooner
um so I think it's actually very good
that we've provided the EV charger
points before
um they they become desperately needed
um they are being used
um and I think there is an answer to to
the use and casts may even have it to
hand
um but we do of course know
um because we charge we do of course
know how much those EV charger points
have been used and I think the rollout
of more EV charger points is incredibly
important we're going to get to a a sort
of a waterfall moment where all of a
sudden we haven't got anywhere near
enough charger points and just to go
back to Lavender
um their involvement in car parking in
lavnum has led to the proposed
Provisions some have already been or
some are already being done
um EV charger points in all three of
their car parks so I think that's
something whilst we might not have seen
much use of them at the moment that's
something that we really must accelerate
thank you
thank you counselor
um uh Casper Osborne you put your hand
up again it is uh do you wish to
contribute something more
yes I do thank you thanks chairman um
comments put very well
Holt and councilor Davis but you know as
a counselor I do not take any decision
lightly however difficult and
contentious that decision may be and
this is certainly one of them and make
sure that my decision is based on facts
and the evidence and we have had a lot
of that provided to us to enable us to
make the decision we're going to make
today
as we are all aware the original
proposal was to reduce free parking to
half an hour
and I would have had a real concern with
this and I have raised it at the the
briefings that we've had and uh my
decision would have been reflected in
that that has now been changed to one
hour
so taking into consideration comments
received and the scrutiny report and
they spent a long time scrutiny eyes in
it I sat throughout the meeting
listening to it and I think it was about
three or four hours I will be supporting
this recommendation it is very evident
that to continue with three hours free
parking is completely unsustainable for
baber Sudbury and our taxpayers
and and again it's been raised by
several members that another concern has
been the implementation date
and again I am very relieved to see that
the recommendation is now going to be
October 20 at the absolute earliest so
I'm pleased to see that
these changes to the recommendation
demonstrates that myself and the cabinet
have been listening contrary to what
some people say we have been listening
and as I've said I will be given my
approval to these recommendations moving
forward to the future
baber Council will be open to talking
about devolved services with interested
parties and I'm aware that Sudbury Town
Council have approached the council to
talk about the possibility of taking
on-car parking services and also looking
for the future baber will be undertaking
the Strategic Park in review which will
provide the opportunity for the council
to look at parking capacity and possibly
solutions for both our Market towns and
throughout the whole district and to
obviously include parking permits so as
I have said I will be supporting the
recommendations and the Amendments that
were made to those recommendations
earlier in the meeting thank you Mr
chairman
uh thank you for that yeah um and one of
the points I wanted to pick up on is is
the fact that we have been listening
there's um we have changed the the
recommendations we've listened to the
feedback
um and we've come to a compromise uh I I
do understand that there are still some
people that um and and themselves not
willing to compromise and to meet us
halfway
um but we've the the reasons for this
are compelling and you've heard them uh
you've heard them from the officers
you've also heard them from from my
colleagues on the cabinet
um is clear uh that uh the the one hour
free uh is something that um many people
will accept the the big problem as as
you've heard from a lot of people is is
the timing
in normal circumstances
um the the issue of when to to do
something like this wouldn't really be a
problem because as you've heard footfall
is not dependent on parking charges it's
dependent on on what our towns have to
offer
but we're not in in normal circumstances
at the moment and um there's no doubt
that Cove is having an impact on all of
our lives and particularly that of of
our retail businesses and other
businesses in our high streets so we
have got to be flexible on the timing
and and we have got to make sure that
that
um uh that we don't Implement anything
until we know that recovery is underway
but in terms of going forward with with
our businesses
um we have uh our vision work we've done
with with Sudbury and moving on with
Hadley and also the other towns in the
two districts
um and we are starting to look at what
we can do
um from from an economic development
perspective uh in terms of
um supporting businesses through
recovery so we we're not doing this in
isolation it will be in in parallel with
other work to make sure that we give the
max amount of support possible to to
businesses
a couple of other points I just wanted
to pick up on the um uh councilorati is
quite eloquently um uh described the
situation over uh how we're funded
through council tax and the burden um of
this on on all of our Council taxpayers
but you've got to remember also that
we've lost a lot of government support
um all local authorities have we're
being encouraged by government to be
self-sustaining financially
and that does mean we have to look to
Alternative sources of income and they
are controversial our commercial
Investments are controversial but are
necessary and are working
but the other thing is our discretionary
services such as parking have got to
take up more of the burden there's no
doubt about that and we have no no
alternative
and finally I just wanted to
um a couple of my colleagues have
mentioned uh villagers nearby and and um
uh their dependence on on the services
in Sudbury and Hadley well I represent
the villages south of Hadley um
and I've been to Village Parish Council
meetings recently
and there is
um a surprising level of support and
understanding for what we're doing even
in the village I represent this closest
to Hadley Lam only a mile a couple of
miles away from Hadley
again they did understand and they
supported the the principle of what we
were doing there was no hostility or
opposition so even the residents of
villagers who have to drive into these
towns do understand the rationale they
do understand the argument they do
understand the case
so
um the timing is the biggest issue
um but we've got to bite the bullet now
we have to proceed with this the paper
is sound it's based on sound evidence
the evidence is there in the appendices
and so um with with the understanding
that we will keep the start date under
review I think this is definitely the
way forward
so
um I don't see any further hands raised
by members of the cabinet
um we've had the debate we've listened
um to questions and and comments today
I think it's now time to move to the
vote so I will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
on on this item of the agenda
Claire please can we now vote on this
thank you chair uh members the boat has
been amended in modgov to include the
agreed amendments
and it is now in progress
thank you
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for that's unanimous
thank you very much Claire right
um
if members agree I'd like to call
um a five minute recess
um before we move on to the the budget
papers if that's all right with with
members
yes
okay can we stop the uh the Youtube
broadcast and we'll it's now 11 36 what
I suggest is we resume at 11 45 that's
that's um just under 10 minutes
foreign
to today's baber cabinet meeting
we're now moving on to item 10 on the
agenda which is paper BCA 2032 the
general fund budget for 2021 to 2022 and
the four-year Outlook
so I just bring that up on my screen now
so I mean please
we're now moving on to 21 to 22 general
fund budget and for your outlook the
report contains details of the revenue
and capital budgets and the council's
Strategic Financial aim
it will enable us today to give final
approval to the budget before it is
presented to council later this month
there have been some changes from the
draft we considered last month although
the position remains broadly the same
as I said last month the financial
impact of code 19 this year has been
constantly evolving and our initial very
worrying assessment has been ameliorated
by very generous government support
a summary of the impact is provided in
paragraphs 4.5 to 4.10 and the latest
forecast is that government support will
fall short of our increased costs and
loss of income by 400 000 pounds
there is again uncertainty this year
over the core funding that will be
available over the medium term
the three-year comprehensive spending
review has been delayed and a one-year
review was published in November
focusing on continuing the response to
covert
the financial support for covert
pressures will continue into the first
quarter of next year as will the rural
Services delivery Grant additional
support for businesses in the current
lockdown is also being provided
the government has confirmed that the
fair funding review business rates
review and business rates reset have
been deferred yet again on details of
these and other features of the spending
review are provided in paragraph 4.18 of
the report
the financial settlement for 2021-22
does give us additional funding of 724
000 pounds
the details of the settlement that
provided in paragraphs form 19 to 422
table one providing a summary of the
financial impact there is a new lower
tier Services Grant from 91 000 pounds
to compensate for adoption in final year
new homes bonus payments a new local tax
local council tax support Grant of 115
000 pounds
there's business rates compensation of a
hundred and eleven thousand pounds and
000 pounds of fifth charge covid-19
funding
this is all now being Incorporated in
the funding in this budget with the
exception of the covid-19 funding which
will be placed in the covered earmarked
Reserve until we have assessed any
additional Financial impact in 2021-22
76 000 pounds of the 115 000 local
council tax support Grant has been
included and will be transferred to the
collection fund Reserve while the
remaining 39 000 pounds will be
distributed to town and Parish councils
Parish allocations are provided in
appendix C
this year the general fund budget
requires 471 000 pounds or 56 of the
anticipated new homes bonus for the
forthcoming year
which will enable us to transfer the
rest to the new climate change and
biodiversity fund
details of new homes bonus funding are
provided in sections 8.6 to 8.10 of the
report
there will only be one more small new
homes bonus payment next year and
nothing after that
fun
excuse me funding assumptions as shown
in paragraphs 8 11 to 8 14. it's a
four-year forecast included in table six
for 2021-22 we will again be increasing
council tax at the maximum level allowed
without requiring a referendum which is
five pounds a year or two point nine six
percent for a Bandy property and we've
built in the same increase for the three
years following
the annual council tax abandy property
will now be 173 pounds 86. there is also
the Assumption of one percent tax base
increase but for 2021-22 this is reduced
as a result of increasing numbers of
people claiming local council tax
reduction scheme
and because of covert and a lower
collection rate
we have based the budget on a 2.2
reduction in the tax base but this may
increase actually if the numbers
claiming support increases
the net effect is that we're only
forecasting our total council tax
increase of 39 000 pounds but this is
helped by the local council tax support
Grant
the growth and business rates income in
8.11 C actually should read 515 000
pounds just for noting there is a
mistake in the report at this stage
table seven a paragraph eight sixteen
provides a summary of the 2021-22 budget
showing the net costs of service income
and funding compared with the previous
year
although we are currently predicting a
surplus of 711 000 pounds for 2020 to 21
but there is still a lot of uncertainty
regarding this
and 364 000 pounds for 200
2021-22 these should be seen in the
context of our medium term Outlook which
I will address in a moment and is that
000 pound figure for this current year I
anticipate uh falling before this report
gets to council later this month
I won't apologize for mentioning again
that we are forecasting a total of 2.28
million pounds from our sifco
investments an increase of 440 424 000
pounds on on last year totally
vindicating our investment strategy
which has ridden the covert storm and is
providing much needed reliable income
the 2021-22 budget setting process has
again seen line-by-line challenges to
identify savings
but the cabinet has also had to make
some difficult decisions in addition to
approving the council tax increase and
I'll summarize the others now
we are increasing the garden waste
collection by 2.50 per annum we're
suspending the under 17's free holiday
swimming for a year saving 38 000 pounds
we are really relocating our customer
exploits and access point is Sudbury
saving 30 000 pounds
and lastly as just agreed we will be
introducing very modest short-term
parking charges as the subsidy we're
providing to our car Parks is no longer
sustainable or justifiable and they must
become cost neutral The Proposal as it
stands will provide an additional 56 000
pounds income of the 2021-22 but I do
stress that is dependent on when we
actually start implementing it
it is worth noting here that the comment
in appendix B paragraph 2.8 on page 132
of the report
that the risk has been highlighted
regarding the relatively low level of
expenditure covered by our fees and
charges income
in connection with this risk ours and it
says also that ours is the lowest
percentage of comparable authorities
so we will need to this this does give a
strong hint that we will need to look
more closely at this in future
and ensure that our discretionary
Services take on more of the financial
burden
as stated earlier we are forecasting a
surplus of 364 000 pounds which
represents the unused portion of new
homes bonus receipts this is forty
thousand pounds lower than predicted in
the draft budget and as I just mentioned
is likely to reduce even further
the overall budget gap for the three
years from 2022 to 23 is described in
sections 8.24 to 8.27 and amounts of
cumulative deficit of 1.4 million pounds
further significant income or savings or
both will be needed to address this
the total new homes bonus column in
table 4 and paragraph 8.7 that was in
the draft paper hasn't been included
here but it will be in the paper going
to council to remind you for the past
five years we have used 76 percent of
new homes bonus receipts a total of 3.52
million pounds to balance the budget
this will no longer be available to us
in the future
the reserve levels are detailed in
paragraph 7.2 table 3. Reserve movements
are slightly different from what I
reported last month we will use 313 000
pounds from earmark reserves for
specific service expenditure but this
will be offset by some transfers in most
noticeably the 364 000 pounds Surplus
from the new homes bonus receipts into
the climate change and biodiversity
Reserve this means that we are able to
increase our research in 2021-22
although the transformation fund will be
slightly lower
I should also mention that the table
hasn't yet included the transferred
funding in the covered Reserve
the capital program is set out in
appendix a and the plan spend for 2021
to 22 is 6.2 million pounds the
financing for this is shown in the
second table in the appendix
the major differences from this time
last year are that we will have
completed our sifco investments by the
end of The Current financial year and
the Bellevue capital investment is no
longer required now that the hotel
project would not take place
in summary we are currently in a good
financial position with a healthy level
of Reserves and helped by the funding we
have received from the government to
mitigate the financial impact of covert
however as I have said the medium-term
challenge is still significant as we
strive to become self-financing over the
next three years
in your report appendix B provides a
summary of council tax billing
information and the section 25 report on
the robustness of our estimates and the
adequacy of our Reserves
Atlantic C shows the local council tax
reduction scheme Grant allocations to
town and Parish councils and finally the
full 2020 to 20 2021 to 2022 budget book
is provided an appendix D of the report
lastly I would like to just draw your
attention to the agenda supplement
um which is appendix e of this report
and relates to the flexible use of
capital receipt strategy
and um I need to explain this addendum
um hitherto it's been the rule that
cattle receipts can only be used to
support capital expenditure
however recent guidance from the
government will now allow some
flexibility and enable Capital receipts
in the period after 31st of March 2022
to be used to fund Revenue spending if
that spending will generate ongoing
savings to our net service expenditure
this could be either through achieving
either reduced Service delivery costs or
reduced demand for services and section
two of of the appendix lists some
examples of transformation projects
contained in the strategy that meet the
criteria for applying this flexibility
so I'd like to propose the
recommendations in paragraph 3.1 to 3.2
of the report but also the additional
recommendations in the addendum which uh
recommendations 3.3 and 3.4 and I would
like to ask for a second to please
may I have a second
I'll second it can Mr chairman thank you
councilor malvisi
right okay so um firstly moving on to
questions from cabinet members councilor
Parker
thank you chair
um yeah I will do if if I can
um 7.5
um if uh Table Three forecast year March
Reserve levels it's on page 115.
um I'm just curious to note that we
include Community infrastructure Levy
funds in there as near marked Reserve
um now I'm sure for the purposes of
transparency that's entirely proper and
correct but it to me that suggests or
would or might suggest to anybody that's
looking at that table that we uh we have
a reserve there that we can we can dip
into and of course we we can't uh as far
as silly is concerned um to prop up the
general fund so I'll just be just be
curious to
um uh have just comments only really
from um uh from our financial officer um
as to why we have to include that if I
can chair thank you
um okay uh thank you councilor Parker um
I should um also uh before I uh go on I
did forget because it is at the bottom
of my notes Here uh thank our finance
team for helping to put together the
budget it has been a very difficult
um uh time for them this this past year
uh given that they've had to do this and
also uh constantly present
um uh covid uh updates to the government
um and monitor how things are changing
in in what has been a very difficult
year
um so I do thank Catherine and her team
greatly for that and I know that
Catherine Melissa and Sharon are all
three of them are here today
um uh I'll I will ask if one of them can
pick up on that but um but you're right
counselor Parker
um still is is in fact he's a ring fence
Reserve um for infrastructure
improvements
um but it is shown therefore for clarity
so that people are aware of of the the
totality of our reserves but it's
certainly not a reserve that we can dip
into to support
um our our general fund
um but uh
would one of you like to comment further
thank you chair yes I can I can come in
there and help answer the question from
from councilor Parker
um yeah we do I know we make it very
explicit in the budget monitoring
reports that we bring into cabinets that
the it's all for information and there
is a set different process in terms of
how seal gets allocated
um I understand the point that Council
Parker is making and that's why we do
show it just separately from the other
earmarked reserves
um but interestingly this is actually a
point of presentation that we're
discussing with the Auditors at the
moment the external Auditors in terms of
whether it should be shown as part of
our reserves or differently on our
balance sheet so depending on the
outcome of that conversation we may
actually show it differently in future
anyway to help with that with that
clarity thank you chair thanks Catherine
Osborne any questions at this stage
no questions at this stage thank you Mr
chairman councilor marvisi
any questions
sorry trying to unmute
um no questions at this point other than
to comment that to drop a budget in the
current covid restriction and the amount
of uncertainty on what is going to be
provided and not provided moving forward
um
means that I think this is a job well
done
thank you thank you Council Holt
not at the moment yeah
councilor Davis nothing from me
councilor Busby
yeah you're the flexible use of capital
receipts Sandra if Catherine can
um perhaps explain a little bit more
about that um particularly
in the paper
12.4 and 12.5 I mean do we it seems
fairly restrictive do we have an
estimate as to what kind of capital
receipts the council might get from the
sale of these assets
Catherine are you able to respond to
that yes chair will try and provide some
explanation
um I think for the general fund it is
going to be quite Limited in terms of
the capital receipts because you can
only use the receipts that you get in
year so if we were sitting on any
Capital receipts from previous years we
can't use those so it's anything that
may be generated in year so it's
difficult to assess exactly when
anything might come to fruition and
might come in so from the general fund
perspective I think it's relatively
limited but it will also apply to the
housing revenue account and they get
more Capital receipts in and I think
we'll be able to take more advantage of
it we can't use the right to buy
receipts for this scheme but if we sell
any of the other properties for any
reasons in terms of you know no longer
being sustainable in terms of
Maintenance or or need then those
Capital receipts could be used within
the HRA under under this flexibility
policy
okay thank you
councilor arthy do you have any
questions
no questions thank you
right um so any other council members
present um if you have any questions
would you like to indicate now please
councilman craw
thank you chair uh I have a quite
specific question and it relates to an
earlier recommendation made in the last
Council year to this cabinet on citizens
advice funding
you may remember we carried out quite an
exhaustive process across Authority
scrutiny working group was set up and
they combined council's collectively
made a series of recommendations one of
which was to include indexing of
citizens advice funding that had
previously existed in other words that
each year there'd be an indexing of the
amount contributed to the two Cas that
we contribute to that being Hadley sorry
being Sudbury and Ipswich to the lesser
extent in Ipswich
we recommended this and we were in fact
specifically charged by the cabinet uh
this cabinet uh if they're carrying out
the review and making that
recommendation now normally speaking we
would carry out our citizens advice
annual review prior well prior to the
budget process in this year and a normal
year that is we don't remember what a
normal year was like now much but this
year sleep we are holding our citizens
advice review uh on the 15th that will
be a week before the council so my
specific question is does this budget
contain provision for the recommended
indexation to the previous contributions
made to those two citizens advice I
don't believe the amount would be large
because it's just an indexation I think
we're talking in this in the sphere of a
few thousand but I would like to answer
to that question it might help the
citizens advice review by overview and
scrutiny to be carried out on the 15th
and it would be better done and dealt
with now rather than waiting till then
at shorter notice
uh thank you Council I must admit I uh
I'm not uh I don't know the answers
where that indexation has been included
Catherine
um can you pick up on that please
um thank you chair I was just uh
conferring with my uh colleagues to see
if we could get the answer to that uh
such a short notice
um it doesn't look like we possibly have
included that but as you say it is a
small amount of money so um we could
always adjust for that before the the
final budget is presented to cancel
later in the month I rather feared that
might be so I wonder if the um last
year's figures and this year's figures
could be provided to overview and
scrutiny uh ready for our meeting on the
15th
um the papers will obviously have to be
ready very shortly I believe it might
even be this Friday
but if that information could be
presented
um that I would expect based on a
previous recommendation we would be
likely to be asking for that anyway and
it's easier to ask for it now than to
wait until uh one week before the final
council meeting to confirm the budget
certainly councilor McCoy thank you very
much thank you uh councilor beer you're
next
thank you Mr chairman
um I I didn't expect I didn't expect to
still be here but uh as this council tax
film was coming up I thought well I'll
just stay
um as I'm sure you're aware very
disappointed that we're going down the
road of increasing council tax uh I do
understand where you're coming from uh
you you have stated it's five pound but
you like oh you know that when we add
all the increases up
um uh the police
um
um part which is 14 pounds 97 so nearly
15 value paying for baber that's 20. I
reckon with the county and the and the
parishes uh you're talking about perhaps
towards ten so it could be possibly
another 30 pounds a year on Bandy and a
lot of people pay much more than bendy
so they'll have a higher amount to pay
um and I'm particularly disappointed
that perhaps we haven't gone as far as
we should have done uh by looking into
staff a staff and whether we can make
any more stay savings there particularly
um nearer the top top level of staff and
um but they're just my reviews and
comments on it thank you Mr chairman for
allowing me the opportunity to say uh so
thank you councilor beer I suspect once
all of those elements of council tax
have been added together it's going to
be substantly more than 30 for an
average Band-Aid property unfortunately
um uh like you I don't like council tax
risers
um the government has put a limit on on
what we can do without holding a
referendum and thank goodness for that
and I agree I think that limit uh is
sensible because it does stop councils
um using council tax as the easy way out
um I certainly would never support a
referendum in baber to to uh increase by
more I I think that um uh we do need to
look to other sources of income
um which we are doing
um and as I've said before and in the
the uh the debate on the previous paper
uh our commercial Investments our
discretionary Services they should all
pick up more of the burden
um rather than uh immediately going for
council tax
um
uh the the last point
I'm not sure whether we've done enough
there yeah into too big a debate about
that at this stage but um yeah you must
be aware that the the successful working
together partnership with mid-suffer has
enabled us to make substantial savings
on on our staffing over the past few
years and it is something that we are
constantly looking into to make sure
that we've got the right resources uh to
deliver the services and no more than we
need
so it is always something that
um is is uppermost in in our minds as
the cabinet but also uppermost in in the
mind of the chief executive as as head
of paid service but um I don't uh really
want to um uh go any further into that
particular subject today but uh thank
you for your comments councilor beer
thank you thank you very much for
allowing me
um chairman councilor beer mentioned um
it's Clive arthy here councilor beer
mentioned uh likely increases in council
tax
um I'm sure he's aware that the Lions
share people's council tax contribution
goes to the County Council so perhaps
councilor beer should have a word with
his County councilor
uh well I will have to come back I will
have to come back
I will allow I'll be allow this question
allow you to respond to that uh well
thank you thank you councilor arfi we do
go back a long way I a little bit
further than you but anyway
um all I'm going to say to that is I'm
going to assure you My Views are echoed
at County as well as well as at the um
police precept that we set last week so
yes I I do I do take it up at every
level and quite rightly somebody should
thank you very much
yes and and I know I I've been told on
more than one occasion that councilor
beer does do that so um he's very
consistent and uh admirably so uh
councilor Mabry
thank you Mr thank you Mr chairman
um some of my questions have already
been asked so thank you councilor beer
for that
um I could have given um you the figures
for the update
um on a percentage for the citizens
advice but considering I'm a director
that may look as though I'm being biased
so I won't
um I am concerned about the increase in
council tax
because it's very evident that there are
more allowances for people and
legitimate allowances for council tax
which actually puts the burden on those
that do pay quite high and I'm wondering
whether the cabinet has an answer to
that please
if you're talking about the council tax
reduction scheme and also uh which we
Implement and that that that is there to
support those residents who really
cannot pay because they claim benefits
um we've also in this past year that um
as a result of covert the government has
provided us with additional council tax
support so
um a lot of the money that they're
getting is in the form of government
grant and such that the poorest
residents in our community are not have
not paid any council tax this year we
still have some additional funds left
over in that council tax support scheme
and we're looking at how we can and and
that's coming up later how we can
apportion that to ensure that even more
of the poorest of our residents are
protected from from council tax so um
the the concept is is
um
uh I think a justifiable one
um I would hate to suggest that
everybody pays council tax at the same
level irrespective of their ability or
to pay or not so um uh I'm I'm concerned
about the the nature of the question to
be honest councilman Avery the the
nature of the question is and I think
you've missed it I'm not I'm not saying
that um people should not legitimately
legitimately claim um a reduction and
allowance be it what what it it is my
question it to you is has the cabinet
looked at the increasing burden on those
who do pay
um
for the future because I'm I've never
been in this situation before but I am
siding with councilor beer that constant
increases in council tax is not the way
to go
thank you for that um we look at all all
of these um issues
um and council tax risers are not taken
lightly nobody likes Castle tax risers
but
um
what we're doing now is is necessary and
justifiable it's it's part of our our
response to having to to become
self-sufficient and ensure that we are
we have a
um a budget not just this year but for
the future that uh maintains the
financial viability of the council and
uh okay
um right I do understand Mr chairman but
I am fearful that you're going to make
council tax so high that it's going to
cause even more issues for residents and
I'll leave it at that and thank you
because we are limited on what we can do
uh with council tax which I've explained
uh or already and so it will not be
rising at uh unsustainable levels
I'll now open this up for debate
councilor Parker would you like to open
the debate
uh no not on this occasion chair I'm I'm
quite content I might join in shortly
thank you okay thanks councilor Osborne
thank you Mr chairman
um yeah just to say really that this
budget's been put together under
extremely challenging situation and and
I think it's a good budget and we've
spent many you know both officers and
also members have spent many many hours
on ensuring that we get a balanced
budget and that's where we are today so
and it's to the benefit of our residents
that we have a balanced budget if we
don't get one then we've got troubles in
continuing to provide not only the
non-statitary but the statutory services
that we provide as well so well done to
everybody concerned it's a good budget
and I commend the officers and I also
commend my cabinet members as well for
the difficult choices that they've had
to make in regards to this thank you Mr
chairman
thank you councilman VC
thank you
um I really can't add any more to what
councilor Osborne has said and I totally
concur with what she has said
thank you thank you Council Hull
yeah just pick it up on Margaret said
ready I'm not quite sure where she was
come from on on the in particular but I
get the impression and she know better
correct me that it's the roll-on
knock-on effect year on year in that the
continual council tax Rises will
eventually come to a point when they are
unaffordable
um so I I think that's where she's
coming from and she does have a point
button we are limited with the tools in
our box that we have to use
and this really stems from a central
government decision to cut funding and
you say we have to be sustainable
um but she has a point that in the
future may be more relevant than today
but um it's certainly one that we do
need to bear in mind and we do bear in
mind when we do these increases
um we don't make them lightly as you say
but um it's the challenges one of the
many challenges we face
it is yeah
um and uh I I as I said
um nobody likes council tax risers
nobody likes putting the burden on to to
one part of our community
um we are obviously facing a future
where business rates are going to be
under increasing threat and the
government's going to have to look to an
alternative solution there but we do
have to fund our services we're looking
at service improvements all the time we
have a continual Improvement service
improvement program in place and so to
make sure that we deliver them in the
most efficient way possible
um and uh as I have said the burden has
to transfer to other sources of income
as well if it's not council tax
our investments
they are a key part of this now and
people don't like them uh they criticize
us but what they can't criticize is the
fact that those Investments are
providing a very substantial and
reliable source of income without it we
just wouldn't be able to function
sorry or can I say they're actually
supplying an income to us to enable us
to provide the services we have to
provide yes and I think there's
certainly um a lot of um
press given to them Investments at the
moment which are
are distorted not necessarily well
placed and well informed and it's
causing a lot of residents to
question that policy
um but for us in particular as cabinet
members we see the benefit
and unbeknown to our residents they all
see the benefit of those Investments and
they've held up particularly very well
over this awful year
um and without them we would be in a
pickle we would yes we very much would
be and finally the discretionary
Services I keep coming back to that have
got to pay their way
you can't just all be put on the council
taxpayer
right councilor Davis
um yeah I'm pretty much in agreement
with what's just been said
um first of all you know commend
Catherine Melissa and and all the
officers that have worked on this budget
it must have been like juggling sawdust
to get to where we are so they've done a
remarkable job in um in in balancing the
book as it were in terms of council tax
on the same yeah I have to pay council
tax resent him to pay more but it's a
necessary evil
um and and as you pointed out Council
award those that are really struggling
do get the help and support in terms of
the discretionary um grants and and
reductions so it's really important that
we do that and and spread the load a
little bit further
um and and again you know we're just
part of that bigger cake if you like
where uh County Council and the police
and social care and everybody else
increases theirs we have to do ours uh
year on year because if we don't and and
I say this at the parish council weaving
and shortly we've increased it by point
five percent
um rather than completely zero because
if you don't um incrementally increase
you're just building up problems for
later on maybe not our Administration
maybe not us as counselors or a cabinet
but certainly build on and and I totally
agree with what you're saying about
sifco we agree with the model uh and
people may not like the fact that uh
that the cifco invest outside of the the
area that's a different argument the
income is hugely important to us and
it's the same as all the other bits that
we we balance a book you can't argue um
against
um car parking charges and then say oh
let's not put the council tax up or
let's not put this up you know the money
has to come from somewhere and I think
the officers and the cabinet members
have done an excellent job in finding a
fair and balanced budget that's me
thank you councilor Busby
thank you Jay yes sorry Catherine I'd
like to go back to that flexible use of
capital receipts
again
um 12.3 the direction makes it clear
that local authorities cannot borrow to
finance the revenue cost of service
reform and we can use Capital receipts
that we get from sale of assets Etc but
as you've said that's likely to be very
limited
have we got any transformation projects
that are pending and how do you see that
we can Finance those then
Catherine can you
we have your transformation fund
obviously if there are capital costs of
transformation which when we're doing
sort of digital work involves it and a
lot of that can be capitalized so we can
naturally use Capital receipts to
finance the capital expenditure this is
talking about Revenue costs and this
flexibility gives us the opportunity to
use Capital receipts to fund Revenue
that's the bit we can't normally do
because normally Capital receipts can
only be used for funding other capital
expenditure or repaying debt it's
usually quite quite limited so the one
or two examples in the in the appendix
as say I think from the housing
perspective uh Gavin Fisk has got one or
two ideas as to how you might be able to
apply it to some of the investor save
ideas that they've got with it within
housing but we will of course be looking
at anything else we could apply it to if
if we get some Capital receipts in doing
21 22 that we could use
yeah I mean you say it's flexible you
know since they won't let us borrow and
we haven't got any assets that we can
probably sell I consider that to be very
inflexible
it's slightly more flexible than not
using it at all or not having the
strategy in place okay new point
okay thank you councilor arthi
yeah thank you chairman
um just a few General points really
um as others have said we um we were all
worried about the effects of covid in
2021 and the pressure on our budget for
as Cabinet member for finance you've
kept us all well informed as you've
sought to deliver a balanced budget
and I'm pleased to say that we're we're
sorry I'm pleased to see that we're
going to be able to provide funding for
um some of our climate change
initiatives including the conversion of
the freighter Fleet to hydro treated
vegetable oil and together with the
infrastructure funding we'll be able to
provide through the community
infrastructure Levy we are in it we're
in a good position to deliver our
ambitious plans so really just to say
thank you for all of your hard work to
get this budget prepared thank you thank
you counselor right well does anyone
have anything else they wish to
contribute to this debate
um
uh councilor Busby
yeah only to say that uh I mean I used
to be heavily involved with the
budgeting process as chair of ons
um and
it's got so much more complex than it
was when I was doing it and uh I really
congratulate the finance team for
uh for juggling this and putting it
together it's uh it is a mammoth task
now it wasn't as easy it was a lot
easier in my day
thank you yes it it is a mammoth task
um and you've got to remember they do it
for two councils
well we're still two separate Sovereign
authorities to separate budgets we won't
go into that no okay
um uh Council cruel yeah you want to
come back on something I'll uh I'll let
you if you have um
this is exactly my place I just
confirmed that in the scrutiny of it we
were impressed with the fact that a
budget was able a balanced budget was
able to be presented at all given the uh
dire situation that all councils faced
during covid-19 we were very very
impressed with that I'd perhaps I didn't
make that clear enough and we also
complimented the finance team I'd just
like some Assurance from members of the
cabinet that they would be uh they are
prepared to support the proposed
indexation of the citizens advice
contribution as I discussed in my
question of earlier I appreciate that
the officer has taken that on board but
I think it's important that if it's
possible for your recommendation to to
include provision for that out of the
available Surplus that you already said
yourself Council award is likely to be
somewhat reduced I don't believe this
would be a significant amount but I I'd
like some indication of support for a
previous recommendation made by scrutiny
and I apologize if this is not the place
but I think there's no other time for me
to do so
uh thank you councilman craw
um I think as as uh Catherine has
indicated the the uh the sums are not
significant so I don't think that should
be a problem to to incorporate that um
but I'll ask uh councilors if they wish
to comment on that I'll see three hands
have immediately gone up so councilor
Davis you were first
just to point out that um we have
already agreed
um that there's a a three-year uh period
where we will continue to give the
grants to the the cab that's already
been agreed so that will be part of the
uh communities
um budget going into the you know when
we have to
um summarize all the budgets and
everything like that so that that will
be available and I'm sure Catherine will
um confirm that when she does all the
check-in but yeah we are um very much
minded to increase sorry to to ensure
that the the cabs for example do have
that Assurance so they can plan further
ahead and that was something that was
agreed uh last year or even the year
before
yeah thank you Council
yes indirect answer to alistair's
question yes I I do approve it
um there were some caveats I think when
we agreed this that obviously over over
and scrutiny would do a thorough job in
ensuring that the ca be were actually
um generating their own income and then
looking at that but again it I'm sure
Alistair will do his job and the
committee would do their job but in this
coming year especially with everything
that's going on it's more and more
important that the cab continue to be
funded correctly and offer the services
excellent services that they do
thank you councilor Busby
yeah I mean I totally agree that
Michael's just said I just just an
interesting point
RCA be open at the moment
I think I can answer that briefly and
I'm sure others can as well but yes
mostly by phone but also remotely and in
fact they're uh Demand on them from
preliminary information I've received is
that they have been as busy as all get
out
yeah well it doesn't come as a surprise
on that I guess the only get busier so
of course we'd like to follow and adopt
the uh recommendations to my ons why
wouldn't we thank you very much share
yourself you know the job thank you
counselor person okay then uh members of
the cabinet uh I think I'll now ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote uh so Claire please can
you open the vote for us
thank you chair uh just to confirm the
vote on modgov does include the
additional recommendations in the
addendum which is 3.3 and 3.4 thank you
um that boat is now in progress
Council Buzz with your hands still up
Joe I can confirm that that is sorry
eight votes for that's carried great
thanks Claire
Right Moving on then to item 11 paper
BCA 2033 the housing revenue account
budget for 2021-22 and the four-year
Outlook
so I'm pleased to introduce support
bca2033 for the 2021-22 HRA budget and
for your outlook it covers both the
revenue account and capital program as
with the general fund it'll enable us
today to give final approval to the
budget before it's presented to council
later this month
uh just to
um uh reiterate what I said uh last
month at the draft budget meeting with a
sound 30-year business plan which will
support our Ambitions to increase our
housing stock and which continues to
deliver favorable positions for both
revenue and capital we've been helped by
the ending of the only one percent rent
reduction imposed by the welfare reform
and work act 2016. the act now allows
race to be increased by CPI plus one
percent for five years from 2020 to 21
and the remaining 25 years of the
business plan based on an annual rental
increase of CPI only
the business plan is a tax Independence
be it shows detail for years one to ten
the new business plan will be presented
to cabinet and Council during this year
and as explained in paragraph 4.2
the plan will include the need to invest
in the existing housing stock for
environmental improvements and safety
enhancements and to build new homes that
meet the draft design code and improved
new build specification
We are continuing with our aspiration to
increase our housing stock
new homes of all types of providers with
new homes burners and council tax but
additional Council housing also delivers
rental income and wider financial and
social benefits
code 19 has had a major impact this year
construction was halted for a period of
property repairs and maintenance were
reduced to emergency repairs only
however void work in order to support
the accommodation of the homeless and
rough sleepers continued when the
renovation of the leases in a matter of
days was an excellent example of what we
were still able to achieve
there's also no doubt that rent levels
have been impacted although in the first
half of the current pronounced year this
was minimal the full extent of this
won't be known for a while and so we
have assumed a 15 reduction for the
second half
small amount of direct code related cost
has been incurred that's forty seven
thousand Pounds for PPE but this has
been covered from our government covered
support there's been no specific support
for the HRA from government yet
the details of the budget are presented
in section five the report Table one and
paragraph 5.2 summarizing the key
elements and the movements from the
2020-21 budget Surplus position of 177
000 pounds is forecast which is a
reduction on the 2020 to 21 334 a
thousand pound Surplus we are proposing
to transfer this Surplus to the
Strategic priorities Reserve
the budget has been based on a number of
assumptions the income ones that affect
our tenants that being a 1.5 rent
increase which represents an increase of
1.1 pound 35 on the average weekly
rental of 91.70.
garage rents will be unchanged there'll
be an increase of 69 Pence a week for
sheltered housing charges and utility
charges will be unchanged
other movements are explained to
paragraph 5.5 the largest contribution
to the reduced Surplus is the inclusion
of 967 000 password depreciation
resulting from a revaluation of the
housing stock
also highlighted here are the key
achievements this year the most notable
being the voids remain at an average 18
days and an excellent effort by Building
Services has resulted in the work in
progress reducing from 7500 to 1 500
outstanding jobs
paragraphs 5.6 to 5.9 of the reports
show the predicted movement in the
reserves the ambitious Capital program
will require funding at 2.617 million
pounds from the street from the
Strategic priorities Reserve as well as
additional borrowing the result will be
a reduction in the overall reserves
balance to still healthy 12.167 million
pounds
tables 3 and section 10 of the report
summarizes the capital expenditure and
financing for the next four years up to
2024-25 and appendix a provides more
detail
and that there are differences between
uh table three and appendix a um because
appendix a includes the carry forwards
new bills and Acquisitions are forecast
to be 24 million pounds over this period
including a carry forward from the
current year
we have worked successfully with IC
needs to develop sites and are now
proposing an additional 161 affordable
and 44 shared ownership homes in the
period 2021-24 and recently Klondike
field worsted has been added to the
sites list
finally I'd like to know the right to
buy sales have again shown a further
reduction and are lower than those
projected in the business plan in 2019
to 20 Beaver sold 11 against an original
projection of 20 sales
we have been delayed by covert and our
ability to use the right to buy receipts
before deadlines for returning unspent
portions to government however the
government has extended the deadline to
31st of March in recognition of this we
are looking at all opportunities to
acquire houses or land before this
deadline so I'd like to propose the
recommendations in paragraph 3.7 341 to
3.7 of the report and I'd ask for a
second to please
and
um
thank you thank you thanks Council
Osborne now um again I'd like to thank
the finance team and also uh Gavin Fisk
uh our assistant director for housing
um and he and the team are here to
answer questions but first of all
um I'd like to open up to questions for
from cabinet members so councilor Parker
do you have any questions
um uh thank you very much Jeff um no
particular questions and I'm glad I read
my papers because you went through that
like a machine gun
um but um I'll just uh make the point um
if I can I haven't got any particular
questions but I would just like to raise
the point about the uh the purchase of
the uh of the homes 117 homes is an
excellent addition to um to the stock
but that's that's not a question that's
uh that's a point um
no questions Mr chairman
councilman avici
any questions no no questions I have
difficulty on muting
yeah the response is not brilliant
um you think you've done it and then you
try it again and you reverse what you've
done
halt
yes um obviously some excellent news in
there about the houses that we purchased
and what we planned to to purchase and
build
um one small concern is is the
um with the green agenda is that we're
actually purchasing homes that obviously
won't meet necessarily the expectations
that we may set ourselves and for the
future
um what can we do to try and ensure
um that the houses we're buying
will actually meet the standards we're
going to be setting ourselves so that we
don't have to retrofit them and add more
costs I understand the houses that we
build we can design and and have them
built to whatever spec we want
but Builders house builders themselves
we're buying model a Model B model C and
what control do we have over the type of
housing we're buying
for future proof of them for
environmental reasons
uh thank you um I see councilor Osborne
cabinet for housing has put up her hands
so I will pass it over to her and I'm
sure she might get Gavin to provide some
some backup and the answer to that so
Council thank you Mr chairman yeah
certainly will
um the team are currently putting
together a design guide and there's been
several member briefings on this as well
and it's it's in quite an advanced stage
and obviously that will set the scene
for those properties not only are we
building ourselves for our affordable
housing aspirations but also those that
we're purchasing or requiring will need
to meet the standards outlined in that
design guide I don't know if you want to
add anything to that Gavin
yeah thank you chair and uh thank you
councilor Osborne um probably what I've
just um add to that is obviously
um colleagues members will be aware that
um the government have been Consulting
on a future home standard
um that is to ensure that uh as an
industry house builders built uh more uh
energy efficient homes
um and as Council Osborne says um I
think our relationship with house
builders
um we're endeavoring to get Upstream um
so that at the very early stage we can
actually try and start to influence what
is built um on our behalf if it be uh
through purchasing and section 106.
um there is lots going on in the sector
um obviously uh currently there's the
drive towards EPCC for all existing
homes
um by 2030 and some of the work that
we've been doing
um in development the hre business plan
today is actually starting to quantify
the types of homes
um not only of size type location but
but build quality and environmental
standards of homes that we may build or
acquire in the future
Thank You Gavin
um Council on my Visa see your hands
gone up did you want to contribute to
this before I move on and just to say
that um
Gavin participated on the climate change
task force and there is a and therefore
fairly up to speed on the environmental
issues that we as a council are moving
forward to achieve
right thank you very much for that
um right so uh moving on for for
questions
um councilor Davis
yeah thanks I've got um two really first
of all I understand uh Angel court
hasn't got the solar panels in and I
know people were looking at that but I I
don't know if anyone could give me an
answer on that and then secondly mainly
it's the Gavin are we going to have to
reluctantly give up on plans to
um convert or build on garage spaces
because of the uh the difficulties in
acquiring whole plots
thank you
um before we move over to Gavin Kessler
Osborne you you put your hand up again
yeah thank you on the first of all if I
could take the garage ones uh we are
still looking and reviewing there is
still a project in place to review the
garage sites the problem that we've got
councilor Davis with this is that a lot
of those sites are
um mixed with owner occupiers and and
also those that we own ourselves within
the council so there is a there is an
issue there and some of the sites coming
forward aren't actually appropriate for
development but it is a project that's
still moving forward and at some point
um I will ask the housing team to
provide an update to the cabinet on
where we are with that actual project
project in regards to Angel Court
um I had a question from a resident in
Hadley on this one and I did put
together a response
um so at the at the time of Angel Court
being designed they used to photo
photonic panels was not outlined as a
requirement
and in this the case for a number of our
projects that are currently on site as
well I'm afraid as you're aware we have
since commissioned the production of a
bespoke design guide which I've just
mentioned about earlier in the earlier
question for adoption with the HRA
business plan this year
whilst this hasn't yet been adopted we
are mindful of this emerging policy for
schemes that are currently being
designed and part of the emergent design
guide concentrates on the council's
sustainability agenda particularly
making inroads towards our Target being
carbon neutral by 2030. so it is
disappointing that solar panels aren't
going to be on this but I don't want
that deflecting from the good
development that this is this is going
to be providing 21 affordable units for
people in most need and I don't want to
detract from that but moving forward
councilor Davis we will most certainly
be ensuring that where appropriate to do
so sustainable means such as solar
panels will be used thank you Mr
chairman fabulous thank you thank you
Council Ross okay oh well that's
brilliant thanks um
the game before I move on councilor
Parker your hand has just gone up is
this on on this particular subject
uh no it's not I've I've just got an
additional question actually yes I've
got it written down but I didn't think
to ask it actually um first time around
then I'll go on to counselor Busby
afterwards
okay well it's just in relation
paragraph 5.19
um uh sorry bigger problem 5.18 uh just
mentions that the council can enter into
agreements with the secretary of state
to retain the full right to buy receipt
so I'm just curious as to as to you know
is this a new thing why have we not done
that before and how are we going with
that thank you
uh I'm just just getting to the
paragraph in the report
page one six four yeah scrolling down is
um
yes chair sorry yeah
yes
um
right yes um I think Catherine can you
pick up on that one
um
I must remember I'm not sure of the
answer to that
thank you chair
um I know this is something that Emily
ATAC has actually been looking into
um in sort of more detail with one or
two members of the finance team so I
must admit I'm not 100 close to the
detail but we can uh find out about that
and and come back to the cabinet I I
think that would be uh great thank you
um it's a interesting question councilor
Parker I must admit um I think we've all
um uh Miss missed that so uh we'll get
to a full answer back to the cabinet on
that one stupid job
actually staying close to that
um depreciation Catherine it's gone up
what 30 percent in the last 12 months
some 3.2 million 3.3 million to 4.3
million that seems an awful lot even
allowing for the fact that we've added a
few uh you know 100 houses
I'm sure the market doesn't
reflect that can you explain that
I know the report does say it's to do
with the the valuation of the properties
but I might need to perhaps bring
Melissa in at this point if she knows
any more than I do in terms of those
valuations
yeah um I don't know the numbers um off
the top of my head but certainly in the
statement of accounts we did have an
increase in those valuations so that
does have an impact on the the future
used appreciation but I don't have those
numbers to hand but I can get them for
you
thanks Melissa okay because obviously if
it's an increase in asset value then as
Cabinet member for assets I'd like to
claim the credit for that
thank you Castle Busby moving on
kasarathi
any questions sorry about that took a
while to find the thing no questions
thank you okay right before we move into
debate then uh are there any questions
from any other members
um of Labor Council present uh councilor
beer your hands up
yes I seem to be stuck here this morning
and listening to you than getting into
it
um I I may not be able to find it
because there's so much paperwork but a
couple of questions to the cabinet
member for housing
um and that is
um regarding garages
um for a start
um Can can she assure me that we are
um still looking into these garages I
did hear a comment on that and is it a
possible solution where there is an
owner
occupier who owns one of the garages say
in a block could we not investigate the
possibility of knocking them all down
with their agreement and replacing their
garage which can be slightly larger for
larger cars and the spaces left turned
into parking spaces
which could have a EV connections but
would certainly help with the problems
of Park and on some of our Estates
that's my first question and my second
part um councilor Osborne is
um is it in the budget somewhere there
money for
help and More in anti-social Behavior a
lot of these problems we're getting on
our Council owned Estates of
um
misbehavior and other things but also
rise and damp seems to be a big problem
in some of our dwellings and I'm led to
believe that this can be considered as
minor Works which is delayed
um I would say to you that if it's a an
obvious amount of rise and damp that is
not a minor work so those two points um
could I just have some clarification on
them thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
councilor beer before I um hand over to
councilor Osborne uh I will um support
everything you said about Rising damp uh
there's I have a particular case in my
ward where there is a very serious damp
problem
um in an extension to one of our
properties because the extension was
constructed poorly
um and the The Damp situation
there is is bad and obviously wherever
it occurs is bad because it's uh it's a
serious health problem absolutely anyway
uh Council Osborne
all right thank you Mr chairman
um if I could take the um garage is one
first councilor beer obviously we're
always looking at opportunities and
we're taking into consideration that
parking is becoming an issue on a lot of
developments and it breaks my heart when
I see them parking on green grass areas
that are really spoiled because they're
parking on them and they become a mud
bath and I can think of some cases just
a few rows away from here where that's
an issue so we yet we do look at that
obviously we have to take the financial
implications in place but we will be
looking at that I think the best thing I
can do is because this is a second
question on garages what I will do is I
will ask for an update on this
particular project to come forward and I
will share it with all members what I
will say is we have some of our
forthcoming projects and this is one of
them coming forward we've had to put on
the back burner for a time being because
of resources being deployed to other
areas because of covid so that could be
one of these projects that's been put on
the back burner but I will ask for an
update on that one and I will let all
members not just cabinet members I'll
make sure all members are aware of that
where we are with that on in regards to
anti-social behavior
um I'm pleased to say that only a few
days ago inspector Kevin Horton sent an
email
to the housing team congratulating them
on their efforts in regards to reduce
reduce reducing sorry anti-social
Behavior now I can assure you that a
compliment from Kevin Horton is not an
easy one so we would take that in due
regard yeah to be in that and it was a
very praiseworthy and if you go into
your update that you get on your emails
you will find that that's been included
in there because I wanted it shared with
all members because it is definitely a
praise for Rowan and his teams in the
work that they've been doing to date I
have also asked I've had conversations
with Lee Cordell about Ring fencing
um some money in the HRA for
um working towards anti-social behavior
and I'm in discussion with the teams at
this point whether that's viable to do
that I don't know but I am in
discussions about that so that will
become forward and obviously I'll let
you know in due course on where we're
moving to that one in regards to the
rising damp I'm going to ask that to um
our assistant director of housing Gavin
if you wouldn't mind coming in on that
one please
yes thank you Council Osborne and uh
councilor B for the questions
um just to uh just just to cover off a
couple of points um the work still is
ongoing in reviewing our garage sites
but um the resource that we've had had
has been invested in
um sites where actually we we can build
quite easily without the need to to
obviously focus on the demolishing um
and construction on on small infill
sites so we've been focusing on volume
um rather than some of the more art
difficult sites but we're certainly uh
that work continues
um just to touch on ASB um I don't think
it's necessarily all about money in
terms of investment
um clearly the effectiveness of our
officers and as a council in dealing
with ASB is related to the policies the
strategies and the procedures that we
have and and we have got a a review of a
lot of that work uh ongoing at the
moment but in terms of resource we have
invested in an additional housing
officer this year to support the work
work in relation to antisocial Behavior
but yes agree with Council Osborne it's
really really nice to receive
compliments about the work and and the
joined up work between the council and
police and stakeholders in relation to
tackling ASB because it is a uh it is
multi-pronged and it does need to be
that way
um in coming to your last point about
Rising damp I haven't personally Heard
lots of stories about Rising damp what I
do here are the stories around
condensation and mold which can be
exacerbated by
um by the conditions in the home and how
the home is being utilized we do employ
external contractors to go out when
issues are raised around damp or or
condensation and they will carry out a
full survey I wasn't aware of any delays
in either that work or the work of our
teams looking at condensation and damp
and mold if you've got individual cases
as members I'd ask you to to contact the
housing service and we can investigate
those individually I have sent them on
to you via the chairman of that
committee so they are existed and they
are out there and I think they're a
little bit more serious than perhaps
you've outlined but anyway take your
plate thank you for your help yeah yeah
thanks Gavin and and just to reiterate
what Gavin said about the anti-social
Behavior the
um the the multi-agency uh work is is
now being improved significantly as a
result of one or two high pro high
profile cases and and that's starting to
have a beneficial effect and tackling
anti-social Behavior
that's because yourself and other
members of The District Council we've
got together and put pressure to bear on
all these Partnerships involved and
we've had to do that so thank you yes we
are women
thank you councilor Mabry
thank you thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm
a few of my questions have already been
answered um thank you to uh councilor
councilor beer
um the one thing that I would like to
ask
um and you're probably going to say it's
not in in this paper but if I don't ask
it I won't get a proper answer I feel is
we have a lot of properties
which when they become void have very
very large Gardens that a lot of people
have said they do not wish to use and I
know people are going to come back and
say to me oh well covert situation
people want larger Gardens but these are
various um excessive in size and I'm
wondering if
um someone could reassure me that when
these properties are void that the
gardens are looked at to see if it would
be acceptable to split these Gardens and
provide an area for yet another
affordable housing that's my first
question
the second is
um
or this is more as a comment is about
Rising damp
um I have had a huge problem in lavenum
and Mr Fisk will know where I'm talking
about and this issue has still not been
resolved and I would like a date as to
when that would be resolved
thank you thank you cousin maybe we'll
take that one offline because that's not
really um relevant to
um to this uh this debate today
um I will pass over to uh Council
Osborne on the garden split but before I
do I I'd like to say that um clearly it
is ultimately a planning matter
um and
um any any potential application for uh
building on Gardens would need to
conform with our planning policies
particularly um with uh regarding
backline development if it's not Road
Frontage Garden but um I'll let Council
Osborne say something more about that
okay thank you Mr chairman
um yeah just to reassure members when a
property becomes void we don't just look
at um put putting somebody else in there
we look at the potential that it's
providing to us and if that property
give us more potential for demolishing
it and building affordable housing on
there plus the one
sorry sorry about that the phone's going
and it distracted me we look at the
potential in regards to the property
itself and the the site itself so for
example if you have a void property come
available and it would cost a lot to
repair that property and it's got a
large garden for example and there's
potential there to knock that building
down and to build two possibly three
which is has has happened in some of our
areas then we will look at that and
that's one of the things we always look
at and then obviously it would fall
within due process within the planning
process but yeah we look at every single
opportunity there is councilor Mabry to
add to our housing stock and take
advantage of any opportunities that are
out there in our baber area thank you Mr
chairman
I think there's an example of that in in
brantham
um currently where where we're replacing
an existing house with more than one
um councilor Davis um uh did you have
another question before we move into
debate no it was just answer and support
and to um give you a cracking example of
being able to utilize large space we had
three uh properties in two separate
plots where
um there were post-war huge Gardens and
we've turned those three which were
demolished into eight affordable homes
so that that's a fantastic use of that
resource uh
discussed it with the neighbors so
everyone's on board with it and it's
going to be a really popular scheme
hopefully finished by the end of this
year
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to come
in here it's councilor Mabry and I'm
very glad that that has happened
in Acton thank you right
um let's move over to debate now
um councilor Parker
do you have any uh no I'm not sure if
you can hear me or not I've I've lost
yeah yeah good stuff okay yeah no I've
nothing to uh to add at this stage chair
thank you okay thanks
um councilor Osborne
oh thank you Mr chairman no just to add
my thanks to the team for putting
together the the HRA report it's a very
good report as always and they are to be
commended thank you Mr chairman thanks
um councilman VC
nothing to add at this stage thank you
councilor holds
uh no it's an interesting point uh from
Margaret and a great example from Derek
how how this is is happening and we're
doing it but um it's a very interesting
point and be encouraged to see some more
developments like that but uh Derek's
spot on with that yeah thanks councilor
Busby
uh no nothing from me thank you
councilor arathi
yeah thanks yeah just a couple of
General comments again
um
some years ago there were councils who
agreed a total stock transfer of all of
their Council homes uh we back then we
decided to keep ours
um but right to buy has reduced the
stock so we are now acquiring additional
homes and building new ones
um to start increasing our stock again
um earlier on
um on a different subject there was
somebody who spoke
um who mentioned our rainbow cabinet and
I think the implications seemed to be
that we might somehow lack unity and
Direction being a rainbow cabinet
um but it looks to me that we really are
starting to deliver now and similar to
the general fund budget
um we're actually starting to provide
for our ambitious plans so once again
this is good news
um and thanks both to you
um and to councilor Osborne as well
because it looks as though we've kind of
turned a corner with our housing
provision
um and things uh things are getting
better so thank you
yeah uh thanks guys and uh it's an
interesting point you you make there
about the stock transfer
um and people complain about our
investments but uh what they do need to
realize that the substantial proportion
of our borrowing is
um that the borrowing we took on to
retain this stock and it uh has proven
to be an excellent investment in housing
I think something just short of 90
million pounds of our uh are borrowing
is is uh invested in the HRA
so uh to all of the accusations that we
don't invest in the district but we
don't invest in homes for our people and
that that is nonsense we we do uh to a
substantial amount and that is
increasing and uh we have a very healthy
HRA as a result of it being managed so
well so um I think our officers have
done a brilliant job here
um I think uh now uh Council Davis your
hand is up uh is that an old hand I
think it is possibly yeah
um I'll now then ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
unless anyone has anything else they
wish to to contribute
okay Claire can you conduct the vote
please
thank you chair
members your vote is now in progress in
the modgov app
thank you chair that's eight votes for
that's unanimous
great thank you very much
um
I'll now move on to item 12 for paper
BCA 2034 the council tax hardship fund
and is that as this is another Finance
portfolio item
um you've got me introducing it yet
again
so I'm pleased to introduce report BCA
2034 concerning the council tax hardship
fund early in 2020-21 at the beginning
of the pandemic the government allocated
money to a hardship fund which is
available until 31st March
um 2020 to uh sorry 2021 and was aimed
at giving a council discount of up to
150 pounds to any working age household
in receipt of local council tax support
our local council tax reduction scheme
allows up to 95 discount on the council
tax payable which means that many
residents have less than 150 pound
council tax to pay for the year
number of payments has risen during the
year in line with increasing
unemployment and was anticipated to grow
more sharply with the end of the
furlough scheme however as the furlough
scheme has been extended into 2021 the
amount of hardship funds spent has
fallen short of the funds available by
about 30 percent this report is
therefore considering and making a
recommendation about how the remaining
balance is allocated to those most in
need of support
having considered different options are
set out in the report the recommended
course of action is that if further
reward is made to those who have already
received some money whilst retaining
sufficient money to accommodate those
that will be making a new claim before
the end of March
this will reduce further the balance
payable for customers and receipt of
discounts and release
the level of additional award will be
adjusted to ensure that the fund is
fully allocated but not over committed
by the end of the financial year this
will ensure that the fund is used in its
entirety in accordance with the original
guidance from the government
section 4 of the report sets out the
funds allocated Beaver the outstanding
balance the numbers claiming local
council tax reduction scheme discounts
and other relevant information behind
the recommendations we're at paragraph
413 there is a table showing the impact
of various additional payment options
I'd like to propose the recommendations
as set up in 3.1 and 3.2 and I'd like to
ask for a second to please
so I may have a second a second chairman
thank you councilor rathi
so um questions from cabinet members
councilor Parker
no questions at this time chair thank
you councilor Osborne
no questions at this time Mr chairman
thank you councilor malvisi
any questions no questions uh councilor
Holt no thank you councilor Davis no I'm
fine thank you councilor Busby
no not for me thanks
councilor arthy no nothing at all
do any other members of the council
present have a question they'd like to
ask councilman crawl
thank you chair I think it's just uh
appropriate
um to ask if we have any idea of what
sort of level uh an upper payment might
be I know it says in that amount that
exhausts the fund I assume that's based
on uh a deadline which must be met
um but I just I wonder if there is any
any indications to what level we might
be talking about
the deadline is 31st of March um so the
end of next month
um
uh so
we're we're looking at um
I think if you see in the report
Catherine can you uh I'm just looking
through the report see if I can answer
the councilman craws question but um do
you have the answer off the top of your
head
so we do need to model the numbers we're
waiting for the the Biff software from
the software suppliers to be able to
model it but I think we're looking in
the 100 to 150 pound brackets
um I do have Amy Mays actually attending
the cabin at this meeting as this
morning as well so um I just pause in
case she's got any more up-to-date
information than I have I mean we have
what's the current
is increa this is an increase from up to
150 to an amount that exhausts the fund
and it's just a matter of trying to
determine whether whether in fact the
final distribution will be Equitable to
those people who have already applied
yes because it will be it will be
retrospectively applied to everybody
who's already had an award we're talking
about increasing it for everybody thank
you so it won't in fact only apply to
latecomers it will in fact apply to all
those who previously have received the
benefit that's all I really wanted to
ask thank you very much all right thank
you counselor
okay
um we'll move on to debate now
um councilor Parker
uh no I was just a good question by
councilor McClure and um I'm glad that
the um that that's been explained
retrospective um so fair and Equitable
excellent thank you
counselor Osborne
oh thank you Mr chairman no nothing to
debate about just to say that your
introduction explained it all very well
thank you very much
thank you councilor malvisi
thank you Mr chairman
um as councilor Osborne said you
explained it very well and
um Catherine Steele also expanded on it
so I have nothing to raise thank you
thank you Castle Holt no nothing to add
thank you councilor Davis
no but I'm glad I didn't have to take
your introduction down in shorthand
it was so quick well done
[Laughter]
I could make a comment but I won't
nothing thanks councilor arthy
very briefly chairman it's an
opportunity to help those in need with
with a little bit of additional
assistance so what what's not to like
yes exactly um we've got the money from
government we don't want to hand it back
we need to use it up and uh we we help
those who who are most in need um it's
uh it's a sensible thing to do okay
everyone well um that uh brings that to
uh a nice quick close so I'll ask the
governor's officer now to conduct the
electronic vote so uh Claire can we open
up the voting please
thank you chair
on moment members
in fact the vote is now in progress for
you
foreign
just waiting for one vote
thank you members that's um eight votes
four chair that's unanimous okay
um thank you everyone and before I move
on to the next item I think it's
probably a good idea to have another
break if um everyone's in agreement
um personally I wouldn't mind a 15 or 20
minute break until 1 30 just to to grab
a bite to eat
um
does anyone have any comment on on that
no
yeah I'd like 20 minutes to get a
sandwich or something yeah okay then
it's now ten past one we'll reconvene at
1 30. uh Robert can we have the YouTube
feed
foreign
right thank you and uh welcome back
everyone to the the last part of today's
cabinet meeting uh hope members of the
cabinet are suitably refreshed and uh
we'll move straight on into item 13
which is paper BCA 2035 adoption of the
revised table Affairs for Hackney
carriages so I'd like to ask the cabinet
member for the environment to introduce
this report councilor malvisi over to
you
thank you very much Mr chairman
um cabinet has before it today
um the revised table of fairs that have
been fixed for Hackney carriages
operating in the control zone of baber
District
this report was considered by the
Licensing and Regulatory committee at
its meeting of the 11th November 2020
following the statutory public
consultation exercise work on the Bieber
Terrace began in early 2020 the
licensing team felt that the fares were
overdue a review there has been no
increase since August 2016.
so a revised table Affairs was produced
a public consultation was carried out in
March 2020 with notices being posted in
the media Council properties and
elsewhere as required in law
as well as recognizing the need to
provide a pay increase for the trade the
licensing no also wish to remove the use
of percentages from the table as this
leaves the fair table open to
interpretation and has led to differing
prices for the same Journey
the response to the consultation from
the trade was high because they believed
that the new tariff would result in a
loss of income
the use of the percentages in the
existing tariff appear to have resulted
in some drivers and operators charging
more than the Tariff had been intended
to allow now let me just clarify it has
to be recognized that charging more than
the Tariff is a criminal offense and the
use of percentages makes the existing
tariff so ambiguous that it would be
impossible to prove an offense had been
committed
in any case there was considerable
dissent from the trade in response some
alternative tariff proposals were
drafted by the licensing team ahead of
the Licensing and Regulatory Committee
in June 2020 and one of these which gave
a much better
potential income for the trade was
recommended to cabinet
there was however some concern that the
level of understanding of the proposals
by the committee taxi tariffs are fairly
complex in their calculations and as a
number of Alternatives were being were
before the committee the amount of
information
before the members was considerable and
potentially confusing the degree of
Engagement with the trade through the
consultation process was also questioned
at cabinet on the 12th of June these
concerns were further discussed and the
decision was that the new tariff
proposal would not be adopted cabinet
referred the matter back to Licensing
and Regulatory committee with
recommendations that further training on
Taxi tariffs be provided for the
committee and they should be further
engagement with the trade
a live team's event was arranged by the
licensing team on the 21st to which all
the baber Hackney driver and operators
were invited the cabinet member for the
environment as well as the chair and
vice chair of Licensing regulated
regulatory committee also attended and
there was a lively debate on both
tariffs and taxi and private hire policy
a more traditional face-to-face meeting
would have been preferable but this is
not was not possible due to covid
restrictions representatives of the
trade were able to ask questions and
make their views known to members and
officers the assistant manager food
safety and Licensing provided her
contact details at this event and this
resulted in some subsequent face-to-face
meetings and telephone conversations
with representatives of the taxi trade
the majority of the Licensing and
Regulatory committee attended a virtual
training session on Taxi tariffs printed
presented by the licensing team on the
4th of August 2020 in addition formal
licensing training which included
elements of Taxi licensing was provided
by an external Trader for all members on
the 25th of September 2020 the feedback
from the live team session was that well
with the trade generated a new proposed
tariff
which achieves the 50 nitrate and 100
Christmas and New Year rate
increases on the basic daytime rate but
expressed without the use of percentages
so that it is unambiguous in addition a
second table Affairs was produced for
larger Vehicles though seating five to
eight passengers
the baber taxi and private hire policy
currently under review requires that all
taxis from plate 21 onwards must be
wheelchair accessible
there was a feeling from the trade that
whilst they are required to purchase and
operate larger Vehicles the existing
tariff does not recognize this the new
table Affairs in effect two tables one
for Saloon cars and another for larger
Vehicles went out for con
consultation during November got I'm
stumbling here no responses were
received from the public and only three
were received from the trade the key
concern from the trade was that the
Tariff for the larger Vehicles was too
expensive and this would mean that
customers would not want to travel in
the larger vehicles
Alternatives suggested were to overlap
the tariffs for Saloon and larger
Vehicles such that the night rate for
Saloon cars also serves as the day rate
for larger vehicles
the Christmas rate for Saloon cars also
serves as the nitrate for large vehicles
and the highest tariffs is for larger
vehicles at Christmas and New Year only
or to base the tariffs on a number of
passengers carried rather than the
vehicle type
Tennessee tariffs are Maximus so a
driver is at Liberty to charge less than
the metered fare nevertheless the
metered Fair must be displayed and it
was felt that this would deter
passengers particularly single
passengers from traveling in one of the
larger Vehicles the discretion to charge
less than the metered fare would also
result in different fares being charged
for the same Journey
The Proposal before you does permit
drivers and operators to set their fares
so that they can make a profit without
within a clear maximum and to charge a
premium when carrying multiple
passengers at unsociable hours
The Proposal before you was considered
by Licensing and Regulatory committee on
the 11th of December and the vote was to
recommend that this be adopted by
cabinet and it was unanimous there has
been subsequent concern from two
representatives of the trade that their
concerns about the Tariff for larger
Vehicles were not debated by the
committee although their representations
were included in full as appendix C to
the report this must be weighed against
the lack of response from the other
eight operators and 205 drivers who were
consulted and whom we must never assume
are content with the current proposal
cabinet May however wish to consider
deferring the start date for the new
tariffs to the latest possible date
which would be first of June 2021
bearing in mind the ongoing effect of
the covert pandemic on the economy in
general and the use of taxis in
particular and before I conclude I would
like to thank Emma Rich Bell and David
Price
um for their very hard work because this
is a real number crunching exercise and
they did it once it got sent back they
did it again
um hats off to them thank you very much
thank you councilman VC
um well I'd be happy to Second this
um and and concur that Emma and David
have put in a huge amount of work
um uh going through this more than one
occasion to to revise the uh the paper
and to support the licensing Committee
in in two of their meetings in in
deliberating and coming to a decision on
this
okay so
um opening up for uh questions from
cabinet members um councilor Parker
first
yeah lovely
um thank you so much um chairman and and
thank you councilor malvaisy for a
really fulsome introduction there
actually and and and that has actually
uh shown a light I'm not sure I wanted
it to actually I've now got more
questions than I had before I started
but um but but thank you it is um It's
really informative
um and it does sound as though there has
been a tremendous effort to um to try
and understand the complexities
um of the matter at hand
so um I have got a number of questions
um but I'll just start off by saying a
para 4.4 on page 176 is quite clear at
the the very last line says maximum fare
should be transparent to Fair paying
passengers and should enable operators
to charge realistic fares so that word
transparent uh to to my mind is what is
is what this is all about um for me so a
few questions
um was the zoom meeting that was held
um was the attendance of that Zoom
meeting representative of the trade as a
whole
um so that that's that's one question uh
and then we we had this issue around the
fact that on the one hand it needs to be
transparent but on the other hand there
is an element of discretion over what
the operator can charge their clients so
um I've received and I'm sure we've all
received a fair bit of Correspondence in
the last 24 hours from from a few um
operators uh and and what I'm not
entirely clear on is whether this
proposal is
unfair to The Operators or unfair
perhaps to the customer ultimately and I
I think that's something that we need to
perhaps go into in debate and I know
we're not here very important point
we're not here to debate taxi charging
that has already been done by by the
licensing committee
um but we are charged with with either
supporting or refusing the
recommendation
um and it's all just a little bit
unclear for me at the moment and Mr
chairman thank you
okay thanks councilor Parker um so the
seriously I've picked up two questions
there
um the zoom meeting wasn't
representative of the trade
um and uh there was a kind of a question
around the fairness of the charging to
um The Operators and and customers so um
perhaps uh if I pass that straight over
to either Emma or David if they could
pick up on on those those two questions
um yes
yes chairman in terms of um
representation at the zoom event we we
the team phoned every operator and
driver and we spoke to everyone and
attained an email address and they were
all invited
clearly in the end we didn't have anyone
um every one of everyone that we called
but we had I think about probably 15
um people which were either representing
themselves as an individual driver or
who operate you know and that were if
we're representing a number of drivers
so
um yeah you can never get everyone to
attend but we did the best we could and
we did have a lively debate on that day
with a good number of people from the
trade
um in in terms of fairness it's always
going to be a balance isn't it
um certainly as councilman Visa
explained with her introduction it's
been a very long time since the trade
have had an increase
um so that was clearly required and it's
trying to achieve something which allows
the businesses to be profitable but at
the same time it not be until expensive
for the traveling passenger we didn't
have any members of the public make any
representations about the current
proposal so again public engagement can
be difficult but the um
proposed Tariff was advertised in the
way that we're required to by law so I
think we have to accept that from a
public point of view they're reasonably
content with the proposal
and in terms of the drivers and
operators yes we have had still a little
dissent slightly oddly that the proposed
tariff is
um perhaps too generous to them which is
a bit that's counter-intuitive but they
have discretion to charge less so if
they're driving a large vehicle but only
one passenger gets in then they can
charge a reasonable a lower price for
that passenger it's it's a maximum
charge which is on the meter
hope that that's helpful yeah thanks
Emma a quick question from uh follow-up
question from me
um is is it true to assume uh that um as
a result of um uh the need for uh
disability access compliance that
increasingly we will see only the larger
vehicles on the road and that they will
ultimately replace a standard saloon car
is is that a fair assumption I'm not
sure that it is talking to members of
the trade it seems to be the case that
many disabled passengers will actually
uh pre-book a private hire vehicle and
that actually just go going up to the
taxi Rank and take a vehicle it's quite
unusual for wheelchair users so in in
some ways we perhaps have more larger
Vehicles than we might have if the
market was allowed to find its own level
as it stands
um in Bay but taxi plates above 20 have
to be larger Vehicles that's in our
policy for wheelchair accessibility but
we are looking at that and that might
well change with the policy review
because as I say I think it's probably
skewed the amount of larger to the
larger Vehicles whereas actually it
would find a more natural level with
more Saloon cars if it were able to
right so there's nothing in the
government legislation that that
stipulates larger Vehicles going forward
no no thank you Council Osborne
thank you Mr chairman
thank you councilman easy for a very
comprehensive introduction I did have
some questions at the beginning but
those questions have now been answered
within your introduction and it's a good
report it explains it what is a very
complex subject in very good detail and
very easy like for a Layman like myself
to understand so no questions at this
point Thank you Mr chairman
chairman you're muted
yeah yes I am yes I was Castle halt
yeah um similar to council Parker really
I have some issues with the pricing
structure so if them larger Vehicles if
you're going to be transparent and the
meter shows one price and then it's up
to the driver to charge you less if he
wants to and arguably should do then I
find that not very transparent
um for a driver to make
the cost the fee up
as he goes along to me isn't the sort of
place we want to be in for our taxis to
be operating in that sort of regime
if I got in a cab
and it was a 560 a cab and I was the
only one in it I would want to look at
that meter and know what I was paying at
the end of The Journey not to have the
driver work it out for me so in that
particular instance I find this very
confusing and it isn't transparent
um and that's the one thing that I
personally have an issue with
um I appreciate it's gone through
licensing and it's um and they voted
unanimously I believe uh Liz said so
um it's certainly
it doesn't sit right with me
um if I was sitting in that cab and saw
a fee on there
and someone charged me less I might be
grateful but I also think well what
should he be charging me so so that's
the one area that I struggle with to be
honest so you've got a question about
the the transparency and um
uh how
how we can um ensure well of course in
his email back in in December quite
clearly sets out an example of what
could happen yeah and um unless the
officers can tell me different that's
not a scenario that can happen it
clearly shows that the meter will say
One Price the driver has the discretion
to charge another price
but if you're leaving it up to the
driver to charge
to set up a fee albeit he cannot go over
the maximum fee I just find that very
ambiguous and
okay transparency in it yeah okay so so
Emma um can you comment on the
transparency and and
um how we can reconcile uh or or how you
feel that um that the drivers will
reconcile the concerns that um have been
expressed around transparency I I do
completely take the point on that one um
I would say it's it's always the case
with any taxi tariff that it's the
maximum that's that's displayed and you
know that there's always discretion to
charge less
um it's a particular issue because we've
developed the Tariff for the larger
Vehicles which apparently most of the
drivers operators are pleased to see
because they they haven't responded they
haven't objected but that is if you like
a weakness in it in that there is
um
some likelihood that there will be
variation in what customers will pay if
they're a single traveler in a large
vehicle I completely accept that on the
other hand it allows
um someone who's driving that vehicle
when it's full of passengers on New
Year's Eve to charge a rate which is you
know
it is appropriate for the unsociable
hours really which I know is was also a
concern for other operators that they
really had such a low ceiling for that
before that they couldn't get people to
work on those sorts of occasions because
they weren't making very much money for
actually doing quite unpleasant
unsociable work so completely take your
point
but it's always there's always the
option for it to be less than the
ceiling on the on the Tariff
is is it true to say Emma that that
obviously
um we we've got to have a scheme of
terrorists that is fair to the drivers
of larger Vehicles when there are um a
substantial number of passengers in
those vehicles
um and and that's what this is this is
addressing it seems that and and would
it be fair to say that uh that those are
the these two perspectives that are in
conflict and and are not easy to
reconcile is is that a fair comment I
would say it is yes yeah yeah okay I
think the problem you've got John is
that these vehicles are more multi-use
and they're more they're more available
as them was sort of indicating earlier
and you mentioned about sort of saloon
cars and estate cars I think from a from
an operator's point of view they're more
multi-use they can accommodate many more
options within a single you you know
single occupancy multiple occupancy
disabled occupancy that those multi-used
vehicles are far more flexible and if
you're a single or or two people getting
in one of those Vehicles you know
looking forward you could eventually be
penalized by paying a higher price
unless the driver uses their discretion
and charge you a cheaper price yeah but
at the same time that's where the
transparency comes in I think it
it's just not clear and I I appreciate I
appreciate all the complexities I really
do okay I think we are in the world we
are we're multi-used vehicles seem to be
the preferred option for a lot of
operators because they are multi-use
yeah okay thanks
um we might pick that up a bit later
um uh councilor Davis
if
if you get out of the station and you
and the only car on the rank is a
five-seater and and you go in there and
the and the meter shows you what the
price is that's what you'll be expected
to pay and yeah okay you might get an
operator that won't but nine I bet 99 of
the time they will and I I don't think
this is fair because you know even if
you phone for a private hire which are
usually less expensive anyway and and
give you a particular price you know
they will tell you this is a 5c it's
going to cost you more or if they don't
you say I'm not paying the full price on
that you can negotiate your private hire
but with a meter legally you have to pay
what what the driver is asking you so
I'm not I'm not very impressed with this
and I wonder why that conclusion was
made
um and if if not if there is not a way
we can be more explicit to say if it's
one two or three people which would pay
ordinarily less to go in a saloon they
should be allowed to pay that instead of
you know the maximum which the drivers
are quite understandably real charge
so the question I I know we're conscious
of merging um questions and debate here
which is not uh surprising on this
particular issue but I guess the
question here Emma is
um
and I'm sure you have exhausted all
other options
um uh in trying to uh enable the the
um the meter to display
a different uh rate tariff
um depending on how the uh how many
people are in the vehicle I mean uh it's
difficult to try to articulate the
question I'm just it's going through my
head as I speak but um uh obviously
we've got one set of uh tariffs for
larger Vehicles one for smaller
um I are the meters capable of of
switching between two
um tariff schemes uh at the flick of a
switch depending on um what the number
of people that get in it if one person
gets into a larger vehicle can the
driver flick a switch to display a
different tariff scheme I think that's
technically possible I might ask David
uh price to answer that one as he's more
familiar with how the meters work I
think I believe it is David can you help
yes I can do yeah yes it is possible for
a flick of a switch for a meter to be
changed if you're minded to go that way
but this the Tariff is set up as one set
for smaller Vehicles one set for large
Vehicles currently
so what would would that be a compromise
then
um we we continue with this separate
tariffs of smaller and larger vehicles
but um uh with the way for the larger
vehicles to um to switch to smaller
vehicle tariff
um depending on on the occupancy
I'm mindful you've got the monitoring
officers yeah Emily did you want to come
in at this point
yes thank you chair um I just wanted to
emphasize that this is a recommendation
of the licensing committee and therefore
the cabinet is not at Liberty to adjust
the recommendations
um you either have to vote to accept the
recommendations or vote against them
yeah thank you yeah thanks for reminding
me of that um
right okay
um
where was I uh Council of Busby you're
next
why
there is a different rate for five to
eight vehicles
should say custom order operator I guess
is that the answer Emma do they
there was concern
um beforehand from the trade that they
were being required to operate a larger
vehicle if they were above plate 20 and
yet there was no recognition of that in
terms of the the an ability to charge a
half a higher fare for that vehicle
based on what that it costs more to run
yes
totally convinced about that these days
but uh
all right
um councilor arthi
um well yeah I mean I've got a similar
question to everybody else really and I
still don't quite understand what the
answer is when when councilor malvisi
gave her introduction I'm absolutely
sure she said something along the lines
of the fair is based on the number of
passengers not the size of the vehicle
I'm fairly sure she said that in her
introduction
um because
um for some months now this has been
something that we've been concerned
about
um and when it was sent back to
licensing
um that was one of the issues
um that we we asked them to look at
um I'm very mindful of the fact that
we've got this paper today and as Emily
says either we accept it or we reject it
if we reject it we send it back to
licensing
um I'm I'm not sure that that's what
we've really ought to be doing I I think
if we can just have some sort of
confirmation of exactly what the
situation is with regard to
um whether it's as Emma says up to the
driver
um or whether the driver should have a
deal rate tariff on the meter
um so that he can push the button
accordingly or if indeed as I thought
councilor I mean I don't have councilor
malves you can come back in if she's if
she's got the text from her introduction
but I'm sure she had a bit in there that
said the fair is based on the number of
passengers not the size of the vehicle
um chair and councilor arthi I'm
currently looking at that text because I
have got it written down
um and I'm trying to locate that phrase
okay I'll give you time to do that okay
um okay so uh councilor Arthur I I just
trying to think if there's a question uh
uh embedded in there for
well it was yeah it's the same question
as everybody else's yeah we need an
answer
um on exactly how a passenger getting
into a larger vehicle how they think
they'll be charged and how they are
charged
well they'll think of what they see on
the Meetup and until and unless the
driver tells them otherwise I think um
is is the The Proposal here is is that a
fair comment Emma
um it's
it's most therapies based on the size of
the vehicle and not the number of
passengers I mean it would be an
alternative way to do it would be to
base it on the number of passengers but
the proposal before you is based on the
size of the vehicle
okay thanks guys have you found the um
no I can't find anything I did say that
the larger Vehicles those seating five
to eight
I I think actually councilor Arthur
Emma's probably just um uh answered your
the question regarding that
yeah well I think I think she probably
has and it's not just my question it's
the question we're all asking oh yeah
um yeah so then the second part of my
question was what do we do if we don't
like the answer and that is that either
um we and we might as well do that now
if that's what we're going to do we send
it back to licensing or we accept
um that you know it's it's a an issue
that we can't resolve
um and I'm guessing that these things
can be reviewed at any time
um and I don't want to sort of put
something off that we're going to have
to deal with later but I mean the other
thing is to accept that it is as it is
um and and see how it goes when it's
introduced later in the year right okay
well unconscious a number of hands have
gone up some of them are cabinet members
so
um uh and we are sort of merging
questions into debate and before I do
move into the debate part with the
cabinet members
um councilors Mabry and McCraw have got
their hands up so it uh if you can
restrict it to to questions both of you
um that would be very helpful at this
stage so firstly councilor Mayberry
uh thank you chairman um I was actually
going to help you out with a comment
from the licensing committee or would
you not like that now I would love that
actually thank you okay fine thank you
uh this question about charging how the
charging would take place with a larger
vehicle was raised because I raised it
and I did ask
um what the operators had thought about
this and I was assured that they had
been asked and unfortunately it
transpired that they hadn't
um my view was this that
on balance it was the way to go forward
however it was a much better briefing
and a much better review than we had had
previously at the first attempt at this
I do see the issues about the larger
Vehicles absolutely
but it was put to us that these larger
Vehicles could actually take someone on
them that used a nobility device such as
the whole thing could actually go into
the back of the vehicle complete with
passenger safely
oh that was my take on it
um
I do actually
uphold what people are saying one
doesn't know how much one's going to be
charged because it's going to be the
larger amount or will a taxi operator
reduce that but we didn't actually have
feedback from the taxi operators on that
issue
thank you but it was but it was actually
given to us that if it was a disabled
person in the larger vehicle then the
taxi operators would be allowed to
charge the lower amount and I think it
was implied that they would so I hope
that helps yeah thank you that's very
useful thank you councilor uh councilman
crore
thank you chair
um this question or these two questions
are based on my own understanding of
Licensing policy having formally served
on Regulatory and Licensing and the
first one relates to 4.1 which states
that
we are setting the maximum rates of
fares for Hackney carriages it's always
been implicit I think in the statute
that we are setting a maximum rate that
has always been the case in my
understanding and presumably always will
be uh that implies automatically that
the minimum we don't set a minimum we
set a maximum and people are welcome to
charge less than that
um that's again my understanding
um the second question relates to uh the
operational cost of a dual
tariff meter I believe that
um such a cost would involve it might
involve complete replacement of a meter
and that obviously carries a charge for
the
uh operator I wonder if that could be
confirmed by officers that there is a
cost involved to the operator and again
this question of fairness might arise
thank you Godzilla Emma can you answer
that question about the meter cost
um on that one again I'll defer to David
I'm sure that will be the case
David
do you want me to answer the first
question first where it's say the
maximum oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yes they are set at a maximum and
it's the discretion of the driver to
charge less than the maximum rate that's
shown on the meter and that has always
been the case has it not done yes that's
always been the case yes so in terms of
transparency it's no different from the
current level of transparency there's no
difference in terms of what's on the
current Table Affairs to the new typed
Affairs you can always charge less than
the current rate okay many people would
be happy to be charged less than they
expected to be charged
um that's only a comment the second
point about the cost of Trent of
adapting a meter
um to a dual tariff or replacing the
meter is that true
ah
it it depends on what what meter they
have each meter is different each each
manufacturer has a different meter so it
depends on the meter manufacture and
what they have have that what they have
and what the driver has been given so
whether they need to change that depends
on the meter itself but of course it's
more than a theoretical possibility
there's a there are likely to be
operators whose meters will only allow
for a single tariff
that wouldn't be correct because there's
now there's currently three tariffs
within within the meter at this stage so
there are okay three tips three rates
currently so we'll be effectively
multiplying our three tariffs to six
yes which is going to be a demand on the
technological accomplishment of the
meter itself as I would suggest is just
a wanting the sum confirmation of that
cost
that the cost exists rather the cost
exists if the meter needs to be changed
yes thank you
right thank you for that okay
um right we will uh I know that some
government members have got their hands
up but we'll move over into the debate
section now and and I will go through
you all um one by one starting with
councilor Parker
any more comments from you debate or
even further questions
um yeah more debate I think um chairman
and um I think what what I'm trying to
uh or what I was trying to drive at in
in my uh comments last time round was
um is it that this is just an
imponderable I mean if cabinet reminded
to send this back again are we are we
any greater
um
um are we any better going to be able to
resolve the stitch in the the situation
that we've got now so listening to the
conversation
um you know it's clear that
um it's not absolutely transparent and
perhaps we should uh we should
substitute that word transparent for
fair so the question is is this
manifestly unfair
um and and as I have been listening to a
bit of debate then I'm not absolutely
sure that it is manifestly unfair so
before we disappear down a hole I think
um unless the officers can tell me
absolutely clearly what they consider
the operator's concerns are that have
written to us I think that on balance I
suspect actually that um that the uh the
licensing committee have have probably
come to their deliberations in a in a
perfectly uh reasonable Manner and and I
think we probably should support it but
um I'd be
um I'd be interested to hear if the
officers can tell us succinctly what
they believe the The Operators that have
contacted us if they what they believe
their concerns are
foreign
could you come back on that
um uh obviously the concerns are are
around
um having to display one fair and and
then uh use their discretion as to
whether they charge something less but
um have they expressed exactly
why that is is a concern for them or a
problem for them
um can you provide us with any
background on on what they've said back
to us I I think I would summarize it as
a concern from drivers and operators
that a single passenger entering a
larger vehicle would see that flag fare
that appears as soon as they get in the
vehicle and would think gosh that seems
very expensive compared to what I've
paid when I've been in a saloon car
they could say that and at that point
the driver could say yes that's the
maximum I will charge in this vehicle
but as you are a single passenger going
to Tesco's I will actually charge you
this probably more what they were
charging their driving saloon car so I
think that's the concern is the
passenger being
dismayed at what they see on the flag
fair but it is the maximum and they can
charge less of course and possibly
wanting to get out and find another
vehicle possibly and they they are it's
um they have to take the first car on
the rank so they shouldn't be moving to
a car behind so if the first car was a
large vehicle then they should be taking
that
okay thanks
um uh Council Osborne
yeah as I alluded
to complex
and that's that's reflected in the time
and the resources that have gone into
getting to where we are looking at this
report today including the licensing
committee which I I understand had some
training on as well to make give them a
better understanding of how this all
works
um you know going back to what councilor
Parker said removing the word
transparent and saying is it fair I
think it's as Fair as it can get I think
I'm of a mind to approve this because I
think we could find ourselves in a
situation where we're backwards and
forwards all the time between licensing
and the cabinet
and and getting absolutely nowhere and I
think we've not got a perfect solution
but I think we've got a solution that is
fit for purpose so I'm of in mind to
support this recommendation thank you
thank you councilor malvisi
uh thank you Mr chairman
um I'm just sitting here asking myself
on what grounds
can we send it back to the licensing
committee
yeah
um I'll just leave it at that from
Members no no that's that's that's
that's that's fair to leave it at that
um uh and uh it's difficult to find any
that's true uh councilor Holt
because she don't agree with it that's a
simple one
um anyway let's move it on from there
um
Emma mentioned we went down the route of
the size of the vehicle than the number
of people as a fundamental uh decision
and that's what this is based on
I would ask the question why did we go
down the size of the vehicle and not the
number of people so that's one question
if it was an option because that would
have eliminated this this query and
um on alistair's point there's always a
maximum fear that absolutely correct
but that fair being displayed would be a
fair price
and you can always come down from that
at the moment what we're left with
is an unfair price if you're a single
person in a larger vehicle being
displayed
so that's the difference I think on what
Alastair was saying yes the fair you can
charge what you want and it's a maximum
fare but if that fare is originally and
and a genuinely appropriate accurate
Fair that's that's fine but if it's
proportionately more expensive which is
what we're saying it is then I don't
agree with it
thank you
councilor Davis
yeah I agree with Michael I think it's
fundamentally unfair onto the passenger
um and and there are
places London for example where you you
don't get charged for if it's five in
the in the cab you you get charged with
the passengers as well and they're all
pretty much single size unless it's
private higher I think this is I
I don't know why they've come to this
but I think it's unfair and there's no
way I can support it okay I'll I'll go
back to Emma in a minute um I just
wanted to hear from councilor uh
council's Busby and arthi
okay the concerns I have with this is uh
or are that it seems to be that we could
be penalizing uh disabled people and
people with say mothers with children
I.E people that have got buggies
wheelchairs whatever that can't get into
a
a saloon car and have to go into a a
larger vehicle
um also
are we likely to see a phasing out of
saloon cars and therefore the majority
of the vehicles being the larger vehicle
as it said for to enable disabled access
Etc in which case that we're increasing
the rates
for everybody quite considerably because
they'll all have to pay the five to
eight rate
they're they're my
real concerns really but and just as a
statement it just goes to show how cheap
car parking is
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay uh councilor arthy
yeah well I I don't really know what to
say about this I mean I I my feeling is
that it should obviously be
cheaper if you turn up to get a taxi you
take the first one in the rank and it's
a big one and you're on your own
um it should be cheaper than it would be
if there were five of you I mean the
funny thing is that I've done both
because I you know we've got a family of
five and and when we go on holiday and
things like that well we don't do that
much anymore because they're grown up
but
um you know you you have to have a
larger taxi so you get to a taxi Rank
and there are lots of saloon cars there
and you think damn because you can't
actually use them
um and of course you have to pay more
um for for the bigger one or wait for
one or whatever it looked at the other
way round it seems completely iniquitous
to be on your own
and the the taxi at the front of the
rank is a seven seater or whatever
um and and that's what you're gonna take
and pay and I I just don't think it's
it's it seems to be
particularly
unwelcome that the only option is to
have a fair displayed
um and the the taxi driver
decides to offer lesson I don't know how
they get assessed for things like income
tax and stuff like that either I thought
they had a a little chip in their meters
that actually tells them what they're
what they've earned
um and I I'm not quite sure they're
going to be very pleased I know they
tend to get tips and they don't go
through the meter
um but I don't suppose they'd be
particularly pleased about having
something on the meter and actually
charging something less because if it
doesn't make it difficult for their tax
return it certainly makes it difficult
for their bookkeeping I would have
thought
um so I don't actually know the solution
but it does sound from what everybody
has said it sounds as though this
particular aspect of it is is a problem
and you know I'm just so reluctant
though to send it back to licensing and
asking them to do it again
okay thanks
um uh that I picked up several questions
for Emma um before I go to her I noticed
uh Cass you've got your hand up did you
want to come in at this point
if I may chair thank you very much
um so it was just a couple of points
there and probably things that you were
about to ask Emma so just a couple that
I wanted to pick up on
um just to confirm that it's actually a
legislative requirement for us to
display the maximum fare on the meter so
I'm afraid that's not within our power
to do anything different and I do I do
understand the um points that are being
raised by members that someone getting
into the cab could see that fair and be
reluctant to take the journey but just
to reiterate that is the situation
that's going on now because of that
legislative requirement so someone would
go into the club currently and see
um that that maximum fare and no doubt
you've got a combination of the person
and willing to say I'm not paying that
and and also the taxi driver not wanting
to lose that fair so it's it's um whilst
it's within their gift to charge that
maximum amount the highest likelihood is
is that they're going to see a a
single person getting into the cabin and
reduced the fare accordingly and say
that at that point
um and also just to say that again
the reason for that increase is that
they haven't been inflated for some time
and so the reports back to us from Taxi
operators was that that they are losing
money and that they do need the ability
to increase the uh the income from their
their Journeys so so just a couple of
points there that I hope
um cover off a couple of questions but
um thank you chair for letting me to let
me come in okay yeah thanks Cass okay
well I will um go to Emma and David
um now so really I think I picked up
three uh questions
um uh one is is is sort of fundamental
one and I think it might have been
covered and answered before but um I
will I will ask it ask it again if if it
hasn't been today certainly on another
occasion why didn't we base it on a
number of people rather than the size of
a vehicle the secondly
um uh if if Saloon cars are being used
less and less and I know and I know
you're uh answer to my question about
um uh the vehicle types that are in use
um will the rate for the larger vehicle
become uh more that the normal rate that
people see
um and and therefore
the uh the the problem over confusion to
the uh the passenger gets gets more
common
and lastly is councilor arthi's question
about
um uh linking the uh output from the
meter into their um tax returns
um uh something I hadn't heard of before
but um can you clarify something around
that please as well
um well I was going to ask David to
answer the one about people versus
Vehicles because I know that he can give
you a better rationale that for that one
than I can and David do please carry on
with other two if you're happy to or
um the rationale around
um the larger vehicle in the smaller
vehicle Choice was purely on the basis
that the abuses of the current rate
um the current rate uh was being used
for bigger vehicles and night rate so
the unfortunately the trade was making
up their own rates as they were going
along with the current tariffs
um hence why we didn't choose the option
for them to have overall discretion uh
on between number of passengers we set
it on the vehicle itself
um if we were going down the route of
fair and S yes you could leave it into
terms of the driver
however if the driver doesn't like that
one passenger it's still open for them
to charge the larger rate because that's
the rate for their particular vehicle
um the questions surrounding tax
that is a totally difficult one for me
to actually answer
um I'm not aware of hmrc plugging into
any meter to take out a taxi driver's
rate what they've earned over the course
of their time between tariffs
um other than that I'm not quite sure
really no I would I don't think Council
arthi was referring to hmrc necessarily
but um uh businesses
um use uh lots of software packages now
to assist with them
managing their accounts managing their
tax returns whether their meter is
actually linking to their laptop
applications that prepare the tax return
data I don't know I mean I'm just um
trying to uh clarify katharathi's
suggestion there and unlikely for them
to be able to plug in they will be able
to have a plug-in for a receipt but
other than that that's all they're
entitled to plug into the meter okay
thank you
um
it's it's hugely difficult one this
because
um it's clear that um
something as as Davis articulated
something had to be done to to change uh
what was becoming a a
some some practices there that probably
needed to be uh regularized and and um
uh some some uh regulation put in around
them we need something that is fair this
one
is uh fair in one respect uh in some
respects but not others it's not perfect
that the the um the big problem that I
have is that yes we've had
representations from a couple of
operators
um but we haven't heard back from the
others uh I don't want to open up a can
of worms that
um if we send it back to licensing ask
them to make yet another change we then
have
loads more representations
um disapproving of of that at some point
we have to make a decision
and
um
it's this is this isn't ideal uh as as
we've said but
um there is flexibility in in this
proposal here
and
um
the the fact that we've only had two
representations I think has has to um
be part of our decision making
councilor arthy you've got your hand up
I've I've run out of things to say at
this stage yeah okay well yeah fine I'm
I'm convinced
um I think we should accept the
recommendations of the licensing
committee
um we've asked lots and lots of
questions about the options with regard
to
um sort of single occupancy of a a
seven-seater
um and I think I'm happy that we leave
it up to the driver we've got to leave
it up to the driver for a number of
reasons
um there's the flip side to this which
is that he's sitting in a rank of
vehicles there's a train unloading a guy
turns up and wants the taxi on his own
but it looks fairly clear that there's
going to be a family of five or six step
off that trail in any minutes and he'd
be able to earn a lot more out of his
20-mile journey with a a van full than
he would do out of a single person I
mean you know this we're starting to get
into the the sort of the operational the
day-to-day
um behavior of taxis and taxi drivers
and know I've never been a taxi driver I
wouldn't I I can't think I've used
enough
um more than enough I think
um and interestingly the ones I've used
in Holland are all electric
Teslas
um anyway
um so I I think that I I will be
accepting
um the the proposal which I think has
been proposed and seconded which is the
recommendation from licensing
thank you councilor Parker
yeah um I concur with all of that
actually um so uh initially started off
very skeptical but having listened to
the conversation I'm convinced that it
is an imponderable actually
um and um councilor Arthur was quite
right the first time around but you know
when you when you arrive at the taxi
rank you you've got whichever vehicle
happens to be at the front of that rank
um and and that in itself you know might
not be fair but but the um but the point
is here is that we're not I can't see
that we're penalizing the operator in
any way so um with all things considered
um I'll be supporting the uh I'll be
supporting the The Proposal thank you
thank you councilor Busby
well actually Joe's going to suggest a
compromise
which is why I like compromises yeah it
issues that we accept the proposal for
the new rates
for all vehicles
I sorry the first the the basic rate
should apply to all vehicles and we send
the five to eight
tariff back to licensing with a list of
all of our concerns and see if they can
come up with something which is slightly
more equitable
so that way you've got a new set of
rates which applies to everybody
uh but it gives us the option to
consider
the issues that we've raised on the five
to Eights
I don't think we can do that
you can
um
it it
says that's effectively saying we reject
the paper because it is is that that's
the um uh reject half of it
I'm sorry I'm probably just repeating
what the monitoring officer said earlier
but I'm afraid we can only go with the
recommendation vote for or against the
recommendation of the licensing
committee on this um you know taxi
policy taxi tariffs are things that are
reviewed regularly and the licensing
team do keep in touch with the trade
regularly so this is something that we
can absolutely commit to monitor as to
how it's going and and keep in touch
with the traders to what their what
their opinions is on this what I would
recommend similarly to the paper
um is to to take
um the recommendation of Licensing
committee but with the absolute
guarantee from officers that we will
continue to talk to trade and we will
monitor the situation and if there is a
need to do anything further in the
future we will absolutely talk to the
licensing committee about that
thank you Cass that's that's very
helpful
councilor malvisi
[Music]
um thank you Mr chairman
um
somewhere in all the debates and I think
it was Emma mentioned that the trade is
in fact losing money
and by not giving them the opportunity
to increase their income
we're not being very fair at all
yeah that's yes and and that's been
going on for five years five years since
the last review so um yes uh it they
really do need
um uh additional income it's it's
becoming quite uh imperative that that
happens yeah councilor hold thank you
thank you
um Cass has really said what I was going
to say
um I I think what officers need to
understand from the fact we've been
discussing this for what the best part
of an hour is that it doesn't sit well
with us
and we do have concerns
um but I was going to say what casser
said really that
I'm not I'm not going to send it back
because I just think that's the wrong
thing to do it's been back once we've
got this in front of us we have serious
questions about one issue on it and I
think it should be monitored I think it
should be
um there should be an engagement process
for the operator to see how it's working
and if it's six months or a year then I
think something something should come
back to us to let us know what is going
on whether they're happy and if
operators are unhappy email us
um but I don't think we can honestly
send this back again otherwise we're
going back to the fours backwards and
forwards please register the fact we've
been talking about it we're not happy
but let's pass it let's approve it let's
see how we get on let's engage with the
operators and monitor it from there yeah
I I agree with that
um uh the the imperative thing is as
Castle malviti has articulated the
livelihoods of The Operators and and the
necessity to have um increased tariffs
in place
um uh we recognize that um there is a
particular concern
um there is flexibility in the system
that allows that concern to be partially
addressed but monitoring has got to be
the key part of this
okay I think we've probably drawn this
to uh a close now everyone has had a
chance to participate
um fully in this and we've asked quite a
lot of questions and um uh got some good
answers from from the officers and I
thank them for for their time here
um because uh it it is a difficult
subject and we have needed to get our
heads around it
um but um we're now I think uh in a
position to move on to the vote so I
will ask the governor's officer to
conduct the electronic vote so Claire
please can you open the voting on this
item
thank you chair
remembers your vote is now in progress
just waiting for one more vote
okay thank you uh that's seven votes for
on one against uh
thank you Claire right we're moving on
to the last item which is the
confidential minute from the meeting we
had last month on the 7th of January
um if if uh I'd rather we didn't have to
go into confidential session on this
it's just to approve the minute but um
you've got it on page 191 of your report
if anyone has any questions or um around
that particular item that we discussed
uh at that meeting then obviously we
will go into a confidential session but
if everyone's happy just to
um approve the minutes then we can do it
without having to go into closed session
councilor Holt
I'm happy to approve the minutes as they
are without going into closed session
and I'll propose them if I get a second
to please I'm happy to second that okay
then okay well we'll go ahead and um
vote on that so
um Mr chairman can I interject
that's okay I declared a pecuniary
interest last time therefore I don't
consider that I'm able to to vote on
this occasion no of course I understand
that so do I have to remove myself from
the meeting
um
no I don't think so you just don't vote
yeah okay yeah thank you okay then so um
I'll ask the governance officer now to
conduct the electronic vote to approve
the minutes for the confidential uh item
uh on uh from last month's meeting so
Claire can you open the voting please
yes chair
okay that's unanimous chair for seven
minutes thank you very much Claire so
everyone that brings us to the close of
today's meeting it's been a long one it
really has but it's been a very good one
I think we've had some excellent debates
and I thank uh everyone for their
contributions to those debates and I
also thank all of the officers for um
assisting us um we've covered a huge
amount of material today
um
one uh fairly controversial item one
very controversial item but
um it's the essence of what we're about
we have to confront these controversial
items from time to time and make
difficult decisions but we make them
based on uh a really good analysis of
the issues and uh a good open and um
comprehensive debate and we've done that
today so I really thank everyone for for
their contributions today so
at least me now just to announce that uh
the date and time of the next meeting
and that's scheduled for Thursday the
11th of March and it's an evening
meeting starting at 5 30.
thank you very much everyone
thank you